JOINT HEARING OF THE SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON WOMEN
WORKING FAMILIES IN THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE ENTITLED
CALIFORNIA'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM. CLOSING THE GAPS IN A
TIME OF GROWING INEQUALITY AND
IF YOU'RE HERE FOR ANOTHER
HEARING OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE IN THE
WRONG ROOM. BUT IF OU ARE HERE
FOR US WE ARE DELIGHTED THAT
YOU ARE HERE- I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO BE A PRETTY EXCITING-
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE LEADERSHIP OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ- WORK
THAT BOTH SHE AND I HAVE BEEN
DOING. FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS TO
TRY TO BRING- CALIFORNIA'S
WORKPLACE INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY SO I AM SENATOR HANNAH
BETH JACKSON I REPRESENT THE
NINETEENTH SENATE DISTRICT
WHICH IS ALL OF SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY AND WESTERN PART OF
INTERNET COMPANIES I CHAIR OF
THE SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE. ON
WOMEN WORKING FAMILIES HI THIS
IMAGE I'M DELIGHTED TO BE
JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE AND
COHORT IN CRIME. OF PRESENTING
THE EIGHTIETH DISTRICT ALL OF
BE HAPPY TO- HIM THE GAVEL TO
HURT SO THAT SHE CAN INTRODUCE
HERSELF AS WELL BUT- AGAIN
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE. CENTURIES
THE WORK OF CARING FOR NEWBORNS
AND FAMILY MEMBERS- AND THE
ELDERLY HAS LARGELY IF ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY BEEN DEEMED AS
WOMEN'S WORK- IT'S ALWAYS
INTERESTING WHEN. I'VE SEEN
WHEN MEN- ARE FORCED TO SPEND
TIME AT HOME EITHER CARING FOR
A NEWBORN OR SICK PARENT THEIR
MORE ANXIOUS TO GET BACK TO
WORK. THAN EVER- BECAUSE THE
ILLUSIONIST BAND THAT WOMEN'S
WORK IS REALLY QUITE EASY- THAT
WOMEN ARE THE ARE THE ONES WHO
SHOULD BE DOING IT- AND THAT-
MIX RESPONSIBILITY IS THE MORE
IMPORTANT TO WORK OUT WORKPLACE
AND OF COURSE THIS IS THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY MORE WOMEN
ARE WORKING. THEY ARE THAN EVER
BEFORE EITHER A SOUL. OF
PRIMARY BREADWINNER OR IN
TODAY'S WORLD THERE INCOMES
NECESSARY EVEN A TWO INCOME
FAMILY IN ORDER TO MAKE ENDS
MEET. I REMEMBER AS A CHILD I
CAME FROM AN INTACT OF TWO
PARENT FAMILY MY DAD WORKED MY
MOM WAS A STAY AT HOME MOM. AND
THEY WERE ABLE TO MAKE ENDS
MEET IN THAT WORLD- THAT IS NOT
THE WORLD TODAY I THINK IF THAT
WERE THE SITUATION WITH MY
FOLKS AND BOTH BE WORKING IN
THE QUESTION WOULD BE. HOW DO
WE ACCOMMODATE WHEN PERRANCE
GETS SICK CHILDREN ARE SICK. A
AND WHEN THEY WERE NEWBORNS IN
A FAMILY. LEE I BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE MORE YOUNG MEN TODAY
WHO WILL BE PART OF THAT
EXPERIENCE THAT. THE EXPERIENCE
OF RAISING CHILDREN OF CARING
FOR NEWBORNS IS ONE THAT IS
RICH. AND SATISFYING EXPERIENCE
BUT THE WORKPLACE TODAY JUST
HAS NOT BEEN AS ACCOMMODATING.
AS IT SHOULD BE- AND ACCORDING
TO A AN EXCELLENT BACKGROUND-PAPER WHICH IF YOU HAVEN'T READ
IT THE SENATE OFFICE OF
RESEARCH. HAS CONDUCTED IT'S
AVAILABLE ON THE SENATE
SEKOLAH. SELECT COMMITTEE ON
WOMEN WORKING FAMILIES WEBSITE.
IN 201650% OF CHILDREN YOUNGER
THAN A YEAR 50% WERE IN A
HOUSEHOLD. WHERE EITHER BOTH
PARENTS WORK OR THEIR SINGLE
PARENT. FIFTY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX IT WAS ONLY TWENTY
PERCENT. SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVEN'T ADEQUATELY
ADDRESSED AND THAT WE MUST DO
AND I HAVE TO SAY- THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA HAS THE VERY
SHAMEFUL DISTINCTION. OF BEING
THE ONLY INDUSTRIALIZED NATION
IN THE WORLD. WITHOUT A PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM. SO IF
THAT'S WHAT AMERICAN
EXCEPTIONALISM IS SUPPOSED TO
BE THEN I SUSPECT WE NEED TO
CHANGE THAT DEFINITION- SO
WHERE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL NOT LEAD- WE IN CALIFORNIA
WE LIKE TO BE FIRST. EVEN IF WE
DON'T NECESSARILY DO IT BEST-
BUT WE DO LIKE TO BE FIRST AND-
WE WERE FIRST BACK IN I THINK
WAS TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR US
THEN SENATOR SHEILA KEWL. OF A
DEAR FRIEND OF VISIONARY IN
MANY AREAS THAT WERE ABOUT TO
TALK ABOUT WAS ABLE TO CREATE
THE NATION'S FIRST PAID FAMILY
PROGRAM NOW IT WAS FIRST IT HAD
ISSUES OF FIFTEEN YEARS LATER
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
AND WE NEED TO THE PATIENTS.
THAT EXIST DAY IN THIS PROGRAM
SO. I KNOW MEMBER GONZALEZ WILL
TALK ABOUT HER OWN WORK ON THIS
AND I THINK THIS WAS A SINGLE
PARENT RAISING A FAMILY THE
CHALLENGES THAT SHE HAD TO
INJURE WE'RE ALSO GOING TO HAVE
WITNESSED TALKING ABOUT. IN
REAL TIME WHAT IT'S- FOR WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO DECIDE
BETWEEN. A CARING FOR OUR LOVED
ONES AND PUTTING FOOD ON THE
TABLE IS TRUST A NON STARTER AS
A PART OF THE DISCUSSION WE'RE
SHOULD BE IN TODAY'S WORLD SO-
WE HAVE A INEQUALITY THOSE WHO
CAN AFFORD IT. ARE ABLE TO-
HIRE PEOPLE AND TO OR TO TAKE
THE TIME WITHOUT THE SAME
CONCERNS. BUT FOR OUR LOW
INCOME OR MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES THIS TRUST IS NOT A
REALITY SO WE ARE IMPORTANT
JUNCTURE GOVERNOR NEWSOME- HAS
MADE TO STRENGTHENING OUR PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM UP I
ALREADY HE IS PUT TOGETHER. A
TASK FORCE THEY WILL NOT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE NEXT.
TWO THAT I HOPE WILL BE A
FOLLOW UP HE. HI Là OR TWO OF
WORKING WITH MY COLLEAGUE AND
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF AS
WELL. AND BRINGING THESE ARE
IDEAS TO FRUITION SO. REALLY IN
A WIVES FEEL LIKE I'M A LITTLE
BIT PREACHING TO THE CHOIR- AND
DO YOU NOTICE PRIMARILY WOMEN
IN THIS ROOM TODAY- BUT THAT'S
FINE BECAUSE WE HAVE A STRONG
VOICE AND WE ARE DETERMINED TO
AND WE ARE RELENTLESS. AND
FEARLESS WHAT OTHER GOOD
ADJECTIVES CAN PUT IN THERE BAD
**** THERE YOU GO AND- AND
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
SO- AGAIN LAST COMMENT. THE
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHITE HOUSE
REPORT FROM THE COUNCIL OF
ECONOMIC ADVISERS REPORTED THE
PAID LEAVE POLICIES HELPED
BUSINESSES AND I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE. THAT THIS IS GOOD
FOR BUSINESS AS WELL AS GOOD
FOR THE FAMILY ONE DOES NOT
PRECLUDE OR EXCLUDE THE OTHER
IN FACT ACCORDING TO THE STUDY
IT HELPS BUSINESSES RECRUIT THE
BEST WORKERS. IT INCREASE THE
CHANCE THAT WOMEN WILL STAYON
THE JOB AFTER HAVING A CHILD
AND SAVE EMPLOYERS THE COSTS
RELATED TO RECRUITING AND
TRAINING EMPLOYEES. THERE ARE
SOME COMPANIES THAT NO THIS AND
HAVE KNOWN THIS FOR DECADES AND
I WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
ONE IN MY DISTRICT. A COMPANY
CALLED PATAGONIA SOME OF YOU
HAVE HEARD OF THEM. THEY HAVE
HEAD THEREOF HEAD SHOT UP ON
SITE CHILDCARE FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. THEY GIVE THEIR
EMPLOYEES PAID TIME OFF TO
REBOOT THEY GIVE THEM THE KINDS
OF BENEFITS AND FOR THEM THEY-
ALLEGE THIS IS A MONEY MAKER.
AS PEOPLE COME AND THEY STAY
AND THEY'RE ALREADY ON THEIR
SECOND OR THIRD GENERATION OF
EMPLOYEES. OR GRANDPARENTS I
THINK IT HAD WORKED FOR THIS
COMPANY. WALK IN THIS ISSUE WE
ARE NO LONGER IN THE LEAD AND
IT IS TIME FOR US SHOP WE ARE
THE STATE THAT INVENTS THE
FUTURE ACCORDING TO OUR- LATE
HISTORIAN. KEVIN STARR AND THE
WE NEED TO AGAIN BECOME THE
STATEMENTS OF FUTURAMA SO WITH
THAT I WILL PASS THE BATON AND
THE GAVEL TO MY COLLEAGUE FOR
SOME OPENING REMARKS. THANK YOU
SENATOR GOOD MORNING WELCOME
EVERYONE MY NAME IS LORETTA
GONZALEZ ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR THE
EIGHTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE I DO WANT TO NOTE.
THAT ONE OF OUR SELECT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. A FATHER
SHOWED UP AND I APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH NOT JUST WOMEN CARE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE- SAYS I THINK
YOU'RE SIMPLY MEMBER KEVIN
MCCARTY. T. JUST JUST TO BE
CLEAR THANK YOU. THAT WOULD BE
pWON I THINK- SENATOR HANNAH
BETH JACKSON REALLY MY WRITER
DIE ON THIS ISSUE I KNOW HOLD
AT WE MADE A PACT THAT BEFORE
SHE FINISHES THIS YEAR THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE- THINGS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GET DONE DON'T WORRY.
THERE IS A LIST OF THEM HER AT
NINE. IT'S GOING TO MAKE SURE
THIS YEAR YES. WE WILL GET AT
SOME OF THESE THINGS ACTUALLY
DONE CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT- HISTORICALLY OF PAID
FAMILY LEAVE. BUT THE TRUTH IS
WE DIDN'T DO IT PERFECT- AND WE
DIDN'T DO A PASSED AND SO AS A
RESULT IN- AND WHAT WE KNOW NOW
THERE ARE SOME I THAT.OBVIOUS
DISPARITIES AND HOW THIS LAW IS
IMPLEMENTED- ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS IS THAT INCOME
REPLACEMENT SET TO SIXTY TO
SEVENTY PERCENT. AT TODAY
HAPPENS TO BE LATINO EQUAL PAY
DAY THE DAY WHEN WE REMEMBER
THAT LATINOS MAKE FIFTY FOUR
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR PER UNDER
WHITE ADD MAIL COUNTY ART. IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THIS IS THE
SHOULD SHAME ALL. YOU TOO IT'S
ON THE- WHITE MALE CAM
COUNTERPART THAT IS THE
LARGEST- PAY GAP OF ANY
DEMOGRAPHIC. AND ONE WHICH IS
EXASPERATED. WHEN. I A LATINO
WHAT OUT ON LEAVE. HAVING A
CHILD AND BEING PAID SIXTY OR
70% OF THAT- OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
NOT NECESSARILY IN MANY TIMES
FOR THAT. THE LOWEST PAID
WORKERS SOMETHING THAT
SUSTAINABLE SO ALTHOUGH THESE
WORKERS PAY IN TO THE SYSTEM AT
THE SAME RATE AS EVERYBODY ELSE
THEY ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY ACCESS THAT LEAVE-
THEIR PAIN FOR IN FACT. WOMEN
AND MEN AT AT IN DIFFERENT
INCOME LEVELS TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE THAT LEAVES SO WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THAT DISPARITY IN AND-
ADMIT TO OURSELVES THAT IT
EXISTS. THE OTHER ISSUE IS
WHETHER OR NOT- A WOMAN HAS A
PROTECTION OF COURSE HER JOB OR
MAN AND I AM SORRY I. PITCH IT
IS WOMEN- BUT THE PROTECT AND
SHOP PROTECTION WHEN SHE LEAVES
AND THAT IS ANOTHER ISSUE WHICH
HIGHLY AFFECTS WHETHER OR NOT-
SOMEBODY CAN ACTUALLY TAKE
FAMILY LEAVE IF THEY HAVE NO
GUARANTEES OF A JOB WHEN COMING
BACK- THAT OBVIOUSLY WAYS INTO
A DECISION SO. IF YOU COMPOUND
THOSE TWO THINGS NOT HAVING THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE JOB WHICH
WERE WOMAN STILL IN MANDATE
STILL DON'T HAVE ALONG WITH-
BEING LOWER PAID- THE- RIGHT TO
ACCESS FAMILY LEAVE IS
COMPLETELY OUT OF THEIR HANDS.
SO WHAT WE HOPE TO DO THROUGH
THE STUDY THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMISSION AND
THROUGH SOME OF THE TESTIMONY
TODAY IS REALLY A KNOWLEDGE IN
THAT FOR THOSE TWO ISSUES THOSE
TWO. ISSUES IN THE. THIS MAN AS
WELL. SECURITY WITH LONG WAY
INTACT ADDING SOME EQUITY INTO
OURS. NO WAY DO WE SUGGEST THAT
PAID FAMILY LEAVE SHOULD BE
LONGER IT SHOULD AND WE I THINK
SUPPORT THAT IDEA
WHOLEHEARTEDLY BUT AT THE SAME
TIME AS WE'RE LOOKING TO MAKE-
THAT LEAVE LONGER WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY CAN
ACTUALLY ACCESS THAT. SO TODAY
I AM I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FOR OUR SPEAKERS AND OUT
CREATING A PATH BY WHICH WE CAN
DO YES. THANK YOU SAM REMEMBER
AND I'M VERY CONFIDENT THAT
TOGETHER WE WILL- STARTER
BLOWING UP SOME OF THESE.
CULTURAL INFIRMITIES THAT HAVE
REALLY KEPT- WOMEN AND FAMILIES
SAID DOWN FOR FAR TOO LONG. SO
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO CALL UP
OUR FIRST PANELIST. PATRICK
CANNING WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. OF
KRISTEN SCHUMACHER WHO IS THE
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER. AND DOCTOR AGENDA
STERN'S ASSISTANT PROFESSOR OF
ECONOMICS AT UC DAVIS. BUT TO
SHARE WITH US- THE HISTORY OF
PAID FAMILY LEAVE AS WELL AS
THE KEY TAKE UP TRANS BENEFITS.
AND SOME OF THE GAPS THAT EXIST
IN THE PROGRAM IN EACH PERSON
WILL BE ASKED TO SPEAK FOR.
SEVEN MINUTES WELL GOOD LUCK.
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ASSEMBLY
PEOPLE- CRITICALLY MY
ASSEMBLYMAN- FOR BEING HERE
TODAY- MY NAME IS PATRICK
HEADING ON THE DIRECTOR THE
PLANET DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT-
AND A PART OF OUR DEPARTMENT
HANDLES- THE DISABILITY
INSURANCE PROGRAM WHICH IS PART
AND PARCEL OF HOW- WE
ADMINISTER THE PAID LEAVE
PROGRAM- I DID WANT TO MAKE OF
ONE INTRODUCTION OF SUCH ALL
RIGHT OF- RONALD WASHINGTON.
WHOSE BRAND NEW TO THE JOB AS
DISABILITY INSURANCE- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT THE DEPARTMENT WHO
WILL ACTUALLY BE ADMINISTERING
THE PROGRAM INTO THE FUTURE.
THE END I'M HONORED TO BE ABLE
TO. DISCUSS ARE PAID FAMILY
PROGRAM BECAUSE THIS PROGRAM-
LONG OTHERS ARE THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT ADMINISTERS IS ONE
THAT IS HAS REALLY BECOME A
PARTNERSHIP- I THINK THAT THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN MENTIONED- AND
THE SENATOR MENTIONED HOW MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WE CHANGED
INVOLVED THIS PROGRAM OVER
YEARS I KNOW THAT IT WILL
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE AND CHANGE
IN THIS ONE OF THE BEAUTIFUL
THINGS ABOUT. A CALIFORNIA FULL
TIME LEGISLATURE IN OUR
MINISTRY TO PROCESS- I'M VERY
THANKFUL AS ACTUALLY THERE AND
HELPED WRITE THE ORIGINAL LAW
OTHER THAN INTO PLACE A VICE
GOVERNOR DAVIS TO SIGN AND VERY
PROUD THAT HE DID IT WAS A
DIFFERENT TIME BACK. THOUSAND
FOUR. WERE MUCH TIGHTER MUCH
DIFFERENT- AND WE STOOD UP THIS
PROGRAM- AS FAST AND AS
EXPERTLY AS WE COULD BUT I
THINK MUCH TO- SOMEONE WAS ALSO
IS POINT- MAYBE NOT THE EXACT
PERFECT THING THAT CALIFORNIA
COULD EVENTUALLY GOT TO WE'RE
HERE AT THE FIFTEEN.
ANNIVERSARY AND I'M EXCITED TO
SAY THAT THIS PROGRAM COVERS
ABOUT EIGHTEEN MILLION WORKERS-
AND IT IS EXCLUSIVELY WORKER
FUNDED THE- DIFFERENT THAN.
SOME OTHER STATES THAT HAVE A
BIFURCATED PROGRAM THIS IS
SOLELY FUNDED BY THE WORKERS
AND PROVIDES NOT ONLY A GREAT
BENEFIT TO THE WORKERS WERE
LOOKING TO- USES PROGRAM BUT TO
THE EMPLOYERS EMPLOY- THESE
WORKERS THESE WORKERS
OFTENTIMES HAVE A HIGHER
CONNECTIVITY TO THE JOB- FIELD
A LOT MORE LOYAL TO THEIR
EMPLOYER- AND. GENERALLY TEND
TO SPEND MORE TIME OUT THAT ONE
EMPLOYER- AS YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH- WHETHER ITS THE-
TAKING CARE OF THE ELDERLY OR
OF BONDING WITH THEIR CHILD-
EXCITED THAT WE HAVE HAD-
RECENT INCREASE UP TO THE- NEW
WAGE RATES NOT JUST HAPPENED-
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE- BILL
WENT FORWARD. A TO RAISE A
BETWEEN SEVENTY AND SIXTY
PERCENT. OF FOR- HIGHER WAGE
WORKERS- AND EXCITED THAT THIS
GOVERNOR SORT OF HAS STARTED TO
PUT HIS STAMP. ON THE PROGRAM
CONVENING A GROUP OF- EXPERTS
AROUND A PERRANCE AGENDA-
TRYING TO IMPROVE THE PROGRAM
FOR WORKING FAMILIES WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN. SOME OF WHAT THIS
WILL MEAN IS A MINISTRATION
INCREASING- THE BENEFIT BROWN'S
WEEKS TO EIGHT WEEKS. THAT
WOULD GO INTO LAW. I'VE OF NEXT
YEAR WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE- WHAT
THAT BRINGS WERE IN FACT GOING
THROUGH THE COMPUTER TESTING.
OF WHAT THE SYSTEM WILL NEED TO
BE UPDATED TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT FOR THAT X.
EXPANSION. I'M HAPPY TO REPORT
AND I'M SURE THAT- OUR CO CHAIR
OF THE SENATOR JACKSON- WILL BE
HAPPY TO HEAR THAT WERE OF VERY
ON TIME WITH OUR
IMPLEMENTATION- FOR PRIOR BILL
TO BRING- EXIGENCY WHICH IS A
WORD- THANK YOU FOR. GIVING ME
THAT WORD AS WELL AS OTHER
UNITS WERE SO YOU FOR. A FILLED
ME WITH OVER A TIME PERIOD HERE.
THAT'S THAT'S NOT YOU DISH THAT
MEANS GET YOUR YOU KNOW SELF
AND GEAR FAST I'LL GIVE YOU
SOME YIDDISH WORDS WHEN WE'RE
DONE THAT ASSOCIATE WITH THAT
BUT I'M I'M SURE HE WILL
SENATOR AND I APPRECIATE THAT
APPRECIATED LEARNING THOSE
OVER. OF MY TIME AS DIRECTOR V.
D. D. BUT- TO BE ABLE TO GIE
BENEFITS TO OF FOLKS THAT ARE.
CAN TO DEPLOY OVERSEAS AND OUR
MILITARY FAMILIES- IT'S AN
IMPORTANT BENEFIT AND THAT
SHOULD BE IN PLACE BY JANUARY
ONE. OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
APPRECIATE THE- TIME- THAT
YOU'VE GIVEN THE DEPARTMENT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT- THAT NEW BENEFIT-
FOR WORKERS- IN A RIGHT WAY. WE
HAVE TAKEN A LOOK AT SOME OF
THE NATIONAL AS IN INNOVATIONS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED ACROSS THE
STATE. AS RIGHTLY POINTED OUT
BY THIS COMMITTEE- WE WHILE WE
WERE THE FIRST A LOT OF OTHER
STATES HAVE. FILED IN BETWEEN-
WHAT'S BEEN MOST FASCINATING AS
A STUDENT OF GOVERNMENT. IS HOW
THE DIFFERENT STATES HAVE
TAKEN. OUR PROGRAM AND HAVE
ADOPTED IT TO THEMSELVES. LOTS
OF DIFFERENT CHANGES IN THE WAY
THAT THEY PROVIDE BENEFITS SOME
HIGHER IN SOMERS SOME LOWER-
DIFFERENT- PEOPLETHAT CAN.
APPLY FOR THE BENEFIT- IN
DIFFERENT STATES WITH DIFFERENT
TAXATION RATES WE HAVE- GOSH.
YOU NAME IT A WHAT ARE PEOPLE
ABLE TO TAKE IT I THINK OREGON
HAS A SYSTEM WHERE- THEY DO
ALLOW STATE- MEDICAL BUT IT BUT
IT'S THE TWELVE WEEKS. CITY
COFFEE AND THE DISABILITY.
PROGRAM PROVIDE UP TO FIFTY TWO
WEEKS. THE PROGRAM OR WEEKS OUR
STATE DISABILITY INTO PROGRAM
IS JUST BEHIND THAT AND AGAIN
THIS IS AT NO COST TO THE
EMPLOYERS IN OUR STATE SOLELY
BORN ON THE WORKERS. I WAS VERY
EXCITED- AND A VERY ALSO
APPRECIATIVE OF- THIS
LEGISLATURE NOT ONLY- BACK IN-
TWENTY FOURTEEN- BUT
CONTINUALLY SUPPORTING- THE OUT
REACH OFFERS BY BY DEPARTMENT
AROUND THIS TO TRY TO INCREASE
SOME OF THE UP TECH- AND
KNOWLEDGE OF THE PROGRAM AN
ITS EXISTENCE. OF SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS- IN OTHER STATES LIKE
IN MASSACHUSETTS OREGON
WASHINGTON. HAVE HAD MONEY UP
FRONT SO THAT THEIR STUDENTS
THREE KNOWS- THAT THIS PROGRAM
IS COMING AND WHAT IT WILL MEAN
THE BENEFITS OF IT- AND TO
PREPARE THEMSELVES FOR- THE
WORKERS AND THE TIME THAT
THEY'RE GONNA NEED. TO BE ABLE
TO SPEND- WITH THEIR FAMILY
INITIALLY WERE GIVEN SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
ACTUALLY THE FIRST BIT OF MONEY
THAT WAS ALLOCATED TO DO OUT
REACH- BACK IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
WE SPEND IT ENDS WELL TO FROM
WHERE WE REALLY YOU SOME MONEY
TO TARGET SOME FOLKS- AS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN. WAS MET EARLIER.
THAT WE HADN'T SEEN TAKING THE
USE OF THE PROGRAM. AS WE WOULD
HAVE HPED- IN WITH THAT
PROGRAM WE DEFINITELY SETON
HAVE SEEN AN UPTICK IN
INCREASED AWARENESS ROUND-
HOUSEHOLDS WITH INCOMES UNDER
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND. AND WITH
FOLKS TO HAVE LESS OF A HIGH
SCHOOL EDUCATION. AFTER THE
SURVEY- WE ALSO SAW POST SURVEY
AN UP TICK OF- AWARENESS ROME
NON AFRICAN AMERICANS OF 11%
FOR HISPANICS ABOUT FIFTY
PERCENT. OVERALL WE ARE ABLE TO
INCREASE AWARENESS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND IT STANDS AT
ABOUT. A 70% FROM PULLING THAT-
WE WERE ABLE TO- DO USING SOME
THE FUNDS ALLOCATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. I'D ALSO BE REMISS
IF I DIDN'T SAY THANK YOU
AGAIN. FOR THE CONTINUE FUNDING
TO DO THE THESE TYPES OF TARGET
AT A RICH TO- WORKERS AND TO
EMPLOYERS. STATE. I AM
CURRENTLY WERE ABOUT TO UP PUT
OUT AN RFP FOR OUR FOR THE
UPCOMING TWO YEARS. I DID WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO TALK ABOUT
THE TRENDS AND USAGE- AND- NOT
ONLY HAVE WE READ WITNESS AN
INCREASE IN PROGRAM ERNEST BUT
ASSUME THAT A SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN PROGRAM SEARCH
INTERSTATE. WHAT WE SEEM FROM
THE VERY EARLY YEARS OF THIS
PROGRAM TO- THIS YEAR'S THAT
WE'VE HAD AN 86% INCREASE IN
THE UTILIZATION OF THIS
PROGRAM. A SUBSTANTIAL PORTION
OF THIS AS A SENATOR JACKSON
MENTIONED- EARLY AS AN IMPORT
VERTICALLY FOR MYSELF BEING. A
FATHER OF TWO CHILDREN- WAS
SAYING THE BONDING CLAIMS AMONG
MEN INCREASE FROM- BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE AT 18% UP TO
ABOUT 40% OF A MAN THAT CAN
CLAIM- THE BENEFIT CLAIMING IT.
AND VERY EXCITED BUT THIS YEAR
WE WILL ACTUALLY PAY OUT OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS- IN- PAID
FAMILY LEAVE CLAIMS- WHICH IS
EXTRAORDINARILY EXCITING AND
WHILE I APPRECIATE THE OTHER
STATES COMING UP BEHIND THIS IS
AS IMPRESSIVE FOR PROGRAM- IT
IS TO BE MATCHED- EDT ALSO.
CONDUCTED ANALYSIS ON
INDIVIDUALS AT DIFFERENT INCOME
LEVELS- BECAUSE WE'VE TAKEN A
LOOK AT- CHANGES LAW AROUND THE
1670% IN THIS UNFORTUNATELY.
WE'VE ALL HAD THE DATA FOR
ABOUT A YEAR- BUT I AM EXCITED
TO SEE WHAT I'D INCREASE.
EVENTUALLY BRING TO FURTHER
UTILIZATION. WHEN THE LOWER
INCOME. THIS IS A MOMENT SALAS
POINTED OUT- THE STATISTICS THE
STORIES- HIGHLIGHT THE
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS OF THIS
PROGRAM HAS HAD- EVERY DAY-
STATE THAT WE HAVE TALKED TO
AND I WOULD SAY AT THIS POINT
IT'S MAJORITY OF STATES. HAVE
TALKED TO US ABOUT-
ESTABLISHING PROGRAM MUCH LIKE
THIS BUT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS APPROACHED US AND TALKED
ABOUT CREATING A FEDERAL
PROGRAM- THE PRESIDENTS.
DAUGHTER I THINK SHE HAS A
TITLE B<c.cyan> FORGIVE ME I DON'T</c>
KNOW WHAT IT IS- HAS. HAS
TALKED ABOUT THIS PROGRAM AND-
I THINK THAT IT'S HELPFUL OF
FRANKLY IS A BIPARTISAN ISSUE-
MOVING ACROSS A WILL AFFECT-
FAMILIES AND BE BETTER FOR. ALL
AMERICAN FAMILIES THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR NEXT WITNESS IS- MS
SCHUMACHER- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET AND POLICY CENTER WHO I
UNDERSTAND JUST RECENTLY.
RELEASED A REPORT ON THIS VERY
TOPIC IT'S ENTITLED. PAID
FAMILY LEAVE HELPING WORKERS
BALANCE CAREER AND CARE GIVING
COMMITMENTS. I BELIEVE THERE'S
ALSO. SOME SLIDES SO YOU'LL BE
PROVIDING FOR OUR-
ENTERTAINMENT- AND HOPEFULLY
FOR DEMONSTRATING HOW THIS
BENEFIT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
AND HOW MANY OF THOSE WHO ARE.
NEEDING THOSE SERVICES WILL BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU AS MENTIONED I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET POLICY
CENTER AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
THAT ARE FAMILIAR THE BUDGET
CENTER IS A NONPROFIT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THAT ENGAGES IN
FISCAL POLICY RESEARCH WITH THE
GOAL OF IMPROVING THE LIVES OF
LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME
CALIFORNIANS SO TODAY HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO REVIEW SOME OF OUR
FINDINGS FROM. A REPORT
SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT THE
BARRIERS THAT LOW WAGE WORKERS
HAVE AN ACTIVE SEEN OUR- PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM. MANY
WORKERS ARE STATE HAVE BEEN
LOCKED OUT OF OUR STATES
PROSPERITY AND ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS THEY'VE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND. IS BECAUSE WAGES
GENERALLY HAVE BEEN STAGNANT
FOR A GENERATION. MR SHOWS HOW
HIGH WAGE MID WAGE AND LOW WAGE
WORKERS HAVE FARED OVERTIME. HI
WHICH WORKERS THOSE IN THE
NINETIETH PERCENTILE HAVE SEEN
THEIR WAGES INCREASE BY ABOUT
43% SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE. AFTER ADJUSTING FOR
INFLATION. HOWEVER ON THE OTHER
HAND MIDWAY GIN LOW WAGE
WORKERS I HAVEN'T SEEN A BIG
CHANGE. IN THEIR INFLATION
ADJUSTED WAGES IN THAT SAME
PERIOD. THOSE AT THE FIFTIETH
PERCENTILE THAT'S THE BLUE LINE
ON THE CHART THERE. HAVE SEEN
ONLY A 1% INCREASE AND LOW WAGE
WORKERS. AT THE 10% TELL HAVE
ONLY SEEN ABOUT A 10% WORKED
HIS MERE 4% INCREASE. BORN IN
LOW WAGE WORKERS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY WOMEN. AND
THEIR DISPROPORTIONATELY BLACK
AND LATIN X. WORKERS. TO AN AGE
OF INCREASING ANY QUALITY IT'S
IMPORTANT THESE WORKERS HAVE
ACCESS TO PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
THAT HELP THEM MAKE ENDS MEET
IN THE CASE TODAY ACCESS TO
PAID FAMILY LEAVE. THE
CALIFORNIA'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM. REPLACES THE PORTION
OF WAGES OF WORKERS EARNINGS
BOTHER CARING FOR THEIR
FAMILIES THROUGH VERY LOW
INCOME WORKERS RECEIVE PAYMENTS
AS WE HEARD AT 70% EARNINGS.
ALL OTHER WORKERS RECEIVE
PAYMENTS A 60% OF THE EARNINGS.
HOWEVER THE PAYMENT RATE OF
SEVENTY PERCENT. ONLY APPLIES
TO WORKERS WITH VERY LOW
INCOMES ONE THIRD OF THE
STATE'S AVERAGE WEEKLY WAGE
ANNUALLY THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. SO FOR A BIT OF TEXT A
MINIMUM WAGE WORKER IN
CALIFORNIA WHO'S WOKING FULL
TIME HERE AROUND WOULD MAKE TOO
MUCH TO QUALIFY FOR THE HIGHER
WAGE REPLACEMENT RATE. WHEN
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES ARE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM THE
OTHER STATES WITH PAY FAMILY
PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
REPRESENTED WITH THAT ORANGE
BAR HAS THE SECOND LOWEST.
PAYMENT RATE FOR WORKER MAKING
TWELVE DOLLARS PER HOUR. AND
TWENTY NINETEEN THAT WORKER
WILL RECEIVE A WEEKLY PAY LEAVE
PAYMENT OF ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
NINETY DOLLARS. ON THE OTHER
HAND OREGON WHICH IS THE NEW
STATE TO ENACT A PALEY PROGRAM
THEY'RE GOING TO FULLY REPLACE
WAGES FOR LOWER WAGE WORKERS IF
ORGANS. LEAVE PROGRAM WERE
EFFECTIVE TODAY THAT SAME
WORKER MAKING TWELVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR WORKING FULL TIME RECEIVE
A PAYMENT OF FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY DOLLARS PER WEEK THAT
66% HIGHER THAN CALIFORNIA'S
PAYMENT. SO AS WE KNOW THESE
LOW PAYMENTS CAN BE A BARRIER
FOR SOME WORKERS AND BOOSTING
THE PAYMENT RATE FOR LOWER WAGE
WORKERS IN PARTICULAR COULD
PROVIDE THE FINANCIAL SECURITY
THEY NEED. TO ACCESS OUR PAY
FAMILY PROGRAM. SO AS WE'VE
ALSO HEARD ANOTHER BARRIER
TAXES THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE IS
THE LACK OF JOB PROTECTIONS
WHEN WORKERS THE TIME AWAY TO
CARE FOR THEIR FAMILY. SELECT A
JOB PROTECTIONS MEANS EMPLOYERS
DO NOT HAVE TO GUARANTEE THAT
THEIR WORKERS WILL HAVE A JOB
WHEN THEY'RE PAID THE PERIOD
ENDS. NO IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT. OTHER STATE AND FEDERAL
LAWS TO PROVIDE UNPAID JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE. FOR WHEN
WORKERS THE TIME OFF TO CARE
FOR THEIR FAMILY AND WORKERS
CAN UTILIZE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AND THIS ON PAID JOB PROTECT
YOU'VE AT THE SAME TIME.
UNFORTUNATELY WHILE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA. ELIGIBLE FOR PAID
FAMILY LEAVE MILLIONS OF
WORKERS ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
UNPAID JOB PROTECTED LEAVE. DUE
TO THE RESTRICTIONS WRITTEN
INTO THE LIES THAT ARE BASED ON
THE SIZE OF THE EMPLOYER THE
LENGTH OF TIME THEY SPEND WITH
AN EMPLOYER. AND THE NUMBER OF
HOURS THEY'VE WORKED WITH THAT
SAME EMPLOYER. SO AS AN EXAMPLE
THIS HER SHOWS THAT FOR INTO
MARKETING CALIFORNIA OVER SEVEN
MILLION WORKERS. EARN A
WORKPLACE WITH MORE THAN FIFTY
EMPLOYEES AND THAT MEANS
THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR ARE
PROTECTED THE YOU'VE TO CARE
FOR A SICK FAMILY MEMBER AS AN
EXAMPLE. IN ADDITION AT ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION WORKERS OR
ABOUT 8% ARE IN ORDER ISSUE
WITH FEWER THAN FIVE EMPLOYEES.
WHICH MEANS THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO. THE JOB
PROTECTED THE IF. UNDER THE
OTHER STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS.
THE WIND ALSO ABOUT WORKERS
WITH LOW WAGES ARE MORE LIKELY
TO WORK IN SMALLER
ORGANIZATIONS THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE MULTIPLE PART
TIME JOBS WHICH MEANS THEY'RE
LESS LIKELY TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
JOB PROTECTED LEAVE UNDER THESE
OTHER LIES WHICH MEANS THAT
PAID FAMILY LEAVE MAY SIMPLY BE
OUT FOR EACH FOR THEM. THE
CALIFORNIA CANCEL. THEIR STATES
IN A CORPORATE JOB PROTECTIONS
INTO OUR PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM. THIS IS GONNA ALLOW
MORE WORKERS TO UTILIZE THIS
PROGRAM THAT THEY- MOST
CERTAINLY WILL NEED AT SOME
POINT IN THEIR CAREER. SO
FINALLY POLICYMAKERS CAN MAKE
SURE THAT WORKERS HAVE ENOUGH
TIME WE FROM WORK TO CARE FOR
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS. THE
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM
PROVIDE SIX WEEKS OF PAID TIME
OFF. WE ALL KNOW PROBABLY THAT
THIS IS GOING TO EXTEND TO
EIGHT WEEKS EFFECTIVE ON JULY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY. HOWEVER
WITHOUT FURTHER ACTION THE
DURATION OF LEAVING CALIFORNIA
WILL FALL SHORT COMPARED TO
OTHER STATES AND CERTAINLY
OTHER NATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE THE
FINAL CHART THE DURATION LEAVE
IN STATES WITH A PAID FAMILY
LEAVE PROGRAM INCLUDING THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA. AND IN
SIX OF THE NINE STATES WITH THE
PAY FAMILY PROGRAM WILL OFFER
TWELVE WEEKS OF LEAVE IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS WHEN EITHER THEY
EITHER EXTEND THEIR EXISTING
PROGRAM OR WHEN THEY IMPLEMENT.
THEIR NEW PAISLEY PROGRAM. SO
EXTENDING THE DURATION OF PAID
LEAVE TO TWELVE WEEKS IS JUST
ONE MORE STEP TO MAKING SURE.
THAT FAMILIES HAVE ENOUGH TIME
AND RESOURCES TO CARE FOR THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS. SO WE KNOW THE
BRUISING PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PAYMENTS PROVIDING JOB
PROTECTIONS AND EXTENDING THE
DURATION OF LEAF WOULD INCREASE
ACCESS. AND UTILIZATION SO
THIRD NUMBER WAYS POLICYMAKERS
CAN MAKE SURE THAT THE SPECIAL
FUNDS THE DISABILITY INSURANCE
FUND. HAS THE RESOURCES TO
PROVIDE PALEY BENEFITS. SO
CURRENTLY PAID FAMILY LEAVE IS
FUNDED ENTIRELY WITH WORKERS
CONTRIBUTIONS THROUGH PAYROLL
DEDUCTIONS. ONE OPTION IS TO
REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO CONTRIBUTE
TO THE FUND RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
PALEY BENEFITS WORKERS BUT ALSO
IN BENEFITS EMPLOYERS TO. WE
WILL BE ALONE IN THIS FOR THE
NINE STATES WITH PAVE THE
PROGRAM REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO
CONTRIBUTE. ANOTHER OPTION IS
TO INCREASE THE TAXABLE WAGE
CEILING WORKERS CURRENTLY DO
NOT CONTRIBUTE TO THE FONG ON
EARNINGS OVER ABOUT A HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND IN ANNUAL
EARNINGS. FOR STATES HAVE A
HIGHER WAGE SO IN CALIFORNIA AT
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND IN ANNUAL
EARNINGS. AND THEN THE LAST
OPTION IS THAT POLICYMAKERS CAN
ALSO INCREASE THE CONTRIBUTION
RATE FOR THIS RAY UNDER STATE
LAW CAN VARY BETWEEN. ON POINT
1% TO ONE POINT 5% IT'S 1% AND
TWENTY NINETEEN BUT I DO WANT
TO NOTE THAT INCREASING THE
CONTRIBUTION RATE WITH YOUR
GRASS. AND BUT HER LOWER WAGE
WERE MORE. AND THE THEY CAN
LEAST AFFORD LARGE. FROM THEIR
PAYCHECK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HELPFUL AND I THINK
THE FACT THAT- WE HAVE TO KEEP
EMPHASIZING THAT THERE ARE
BENEFITS TO THE EMPLOYERS WELL-
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR SAYING
THAT I DID WANT TO MAKE ONE
POINT- TO THE DIRECTOR HAD
THINGS COMMENTS ABOUT THE-
FIRST DAUGHTER WHATEVER HER
TITLE IS THAT HER PROPOSAL IS
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO RAID THEIR
SOCIAL SECURITY TO PAY FOR
FAMILY LEAVE AND I HOPE WE
DON'T GO ANYWHERE NEAR THAT.
NOTION THE ALREADY OF BEING
THAT SAFE. SO WHILE I
APPRECIATE THE RESERVE SOMEWHAT
OF A FULL. ON THIS ISSUE- THAT
KIND OF AN APPROACH I THINK
WOULD BE TERRIBLY. REGRESSIVE
AS YOU POLITELY PUT IT SO- I
AGREE THIS IS A NON PARTISAN
ISSUE. PEOPLE WHO VOTE ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER STILL HAVE THE SAME
FAMILY ISSUES TO ATTEND TO AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN. DO WITHOUT
WITHOUT REALLY PUTTING FAMILIES
AT RISK AND PUNISHING THEM
WHICH ESSENTIALLY IS WHAT WE DO.
IF WE START TAKING MONEY OUT OF
PEOPLE'S POCKETS AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO. SENATOR IF I MAY
APOLOGIZE IF I SEEM TO AND FOR
THAT- THE FEDERAL PROGRAM- THE
POLICIES THAT ARE OUT THERE.
ARE SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER IN AS MUCH AS- THAT WE
HAVE THE BEST A POLICY
CURRENTLY- IN ALL THE STATES-
AND STILL COULD BE A LITTLE BIT
BETTER HERE. I UST THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT CLARIFY BECAUSE AS
MUCH AS WE REALLY WANT I PART
IN NONPARTISAN ON THIS ISSUE.
THERE ARE SOME PARTS OF
PROPOSAL'S LITERATURE THE SITE
TO ME. PROBABLY TO THE PROCESS
NON STARTERS SO BUT THANK YOU
ARE AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THEM INFORMATIVE OF
PRESENTATION AND IT DID COME IN
UNDER. EIGHT MINUTES BY THE WAY
JUST. THOUGHT I WOULD SHARE
THAT WITH YOU. ALL RIGHT AND-
WE NEXT HAVE- LEADING EXPERT ON
THE BENEFITS OF PAID FAMILY
LEAVE WITH AN ACUTE
UNDERSTANDING OF CALIFORNIA'S
PROGRAM DOCTOR JANICE STERN'S
FROM. UC DAVIS I WAS A- DOCTOR.
YES IT'S WONDERFUL THAT. TO BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT TO HAVE YOU
HERE. THANK YOU FOR- YOUR-
BEING WITH US TODAY. YOU THINK
YEAH- SO I AM AN ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR AT OF ECONOMICS AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DAVIS. AND MY RESEARH FOCUSES
ON THE EFFECTS OF PAID FAMILY
LEAVE ANOTHER SOCIAL INSURANCE
POLICIES ON LABOR MARKET
OUTCOMES AND HEALTH. SO I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF. PAID
FAMILY LEAVE TODAY I WANTED TO
START BY JUST. A POINT THAT
SENATOR JACKSON BROUGHT UP
EARLIER WHICH IS NOW TODAY IN
THE UNITED. RENTS AND MOST
MOTHERS OF YOUNG CHILDREN NOW
WORK OUT SIDE OF THE HOME AND
SO THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN IN A
AN ACT POLICIES THAT HELP
BRIDGE THE GAP BETWEEN WORK AND
STARTING A NEW FAMILY OR
BRINGING NEW LIFE INTO THE
HOUSEHOLD ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
IT ABSENCE OF A PAID FAMILY
LEAVE YES ACCESS TO EMPLOYER
PROVIDED PAID LEAVE IN THE
UNITED STATES INCREDIBLY LOW
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY THAN THE
LOW RATE OVERALL IS THERE'S AN
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF IN EQUITY
IN ACCESS TO EMPLOYER PROVIDED
LEAVE ONLY ABOUT 9% OF WORKERS
IN THE BOTTOM 25% OF THE WAGE
DISTRIBUTION HAVE ACCESS TO
EMPLOYER PROVIDED THESE
BENEFITS. COMPARED ABOUT THIRTY
IN THE TOP 25% WHICH- AND SO
POLICIES SUCH AS CALIFORNIA'S
CAN HAVE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
DISTRIBUTION OF CONSEQUENCES
ACCESS TO THESE TYPES OF
BENEFITS. I'M GONNA TALK A
LITTLE BIT JUST VERY BRIEF. THE
BENEFITS OF CALIFORNIA'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE IN OTHER PROGRAMS
ON. HEALTH AND EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES IN A MINISTER WITH
EVIDENCE ON CHILDREN'S HEALTH.
I THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT
PAID FAMILY LEAVE HAS
UNAMBIGUOUS UNAMBIGUOUSLY
POSITIVE EFFECTS ON CHILDREN'S
HEALTH. IN THE- AT THE TIME
THEY'RE BORN IN PERSISTING
LEADER IN LIFE. SO IN THE SHORT
RUN- SOME WORK THAT I'VE DONE
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF PAID
MATERNITY LEAVE UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE PROGRAM AND OTHER
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
PROGRAMS HAS SHOWN THAT PAID
MATERNITY LEAVE. THE ACTUALLY
IMPROVED INTENT HEALTH AT
BIRTH- SO THIS FIGURE HERE
SHOWS WHAT HAPPENS TO THE SHARE
OF LOW BIRTH WEIGHT BIRTHS IN
THE STATE. THAT LIMIT OF PAID
MATERNITY LEAVE THROUGH THEIR
BILL THE INTERNS. IN THE SOUL.
COMPARED TO WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE LOW BIRTH WEIGHT RATE IN
STATES THAT DID NOT IN THAT
DASHLANE YOU CAN SEE. AS SOON
AS PAID MATERNITY LEAVE- BECAME
AVAILABLE THERE WAS A
SUBSTANTIAL DECLINE IN THE
SHARE OF LOW BIRTH WEIGHT BIRTH
WE ALSO SEE IMPROVEMENTS IN
OTHER MEASURES OF INFANT. BIRTH
WE ALSO KNOW FROM THAT
PRODUCTION OF THE FEDERAL
FAMILY AND MEDICAL LEAVE ACT
THE ACCESS TO UNPAID LEAVE ALSO
IMPROVES BIRTH OUTCOMES. BUT
ONE IMPORTANT DISTINCTION I
THINK IS THAT- WHEN WE PROVIDE
ACCESS TO UNPAID LEAVE BENEFITS
ARE RELATIVELY LARGER AMONG
MORE ADVANTAGE HIGHER SKILLED
WORKERS WHEREAS WHEN WE
IMPLEMENTED THESE. PAID
MATERNITY PROGRAMS WE SAW
RELATIVELY LARGER BENEFITS
AMONG THE LOWER SKILLED LESS
ADVANTAGED WORKER. AND SO HE
LEAVE MAY HAVE VERY IMPORTANT
EQUITY IMPLICATIONS IN THAT
REGARD. CALIFORNIA'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM IN
PARTICULAR ALSO HAS BEEN
SHIPPED TO HAVE A FAX ONE
INFANT HEALTH WE SEE INCREASES
IN- THE AMOUNT OF TIME MOTHER
SPEND BREAST FEEDING WITH THEM
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
A DECREASE IN THE PROBABILITY
THAT INFANTS ARE HOSPITALIZED
DUE TO SEVERE. ILLNESS OR
INFECTION AND A DECREASE IN THE
LEAGUE VACCINATION RATES SO
INFANTS ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
ON THE RECOMMENDED ROUTINE
VACCINATION SCHEDULE THAT NOT
ONLY HAS IMPORTANT IMPLICATIONS.
CARRY ON LONGER AND LIFE A NEW
WORKING A NEW PAPER SHOWS THAT.
INFANTS EXPOSED TO PAID FAMILY
LEAVE HAVE IMPROVED HEALTH IN
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH A LOWER-
PROBABILITY OF. BEING OVER
WEIGHT- LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
HEARING PROBLEMS AND ALSO LESS
LIKELY TO BE A NOTE DIAGNOSED
WITH ADHD. EACH OF THESE HEALTH
OUTCOMES- IT CAN BE CORRELATED
WITH THE SHORT RUN DEFECTS AND
HEALTH THAT WE SEE PRIMARILY
THROUGH BREAST FEEDING AND- A
DECREASE IN THE PROBABILITY OF
ILLNESS AS A AS A- CHILD. WE
ALSO SEE THAT PAID FAMILY LEAVE
INCREASES PARENTAL TIME IN
CHILD CARE WHICH HAS IMPORTANT
IMPLICATIONS FOR CHILDREN'S
HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENT. AND
THIS IS NOT FROM THE UNITED
STATES BUT THE INTRODUCTION OF
PAID MATERNITY LEAVE IN NORWAY
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES HAS
BEEN SHOWN. TO ACTUALLY HAVE
SUBSTANTIAL IMPACTS ON THE LONG
TERM EARNINGS OF THE CHILDREN
EXPOSED TO THAT LEAVES.
OBVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA'S POLICY
IS NOT YET OLD ENOUGH TO LOOK
AT LONG TERM IMPACTS ON ADULT
EARNINGS BUT THERE MAY BE ON
REALIZE BENEFITS IN A FORMAT
THAT WE- CAN'T MEASURE YET.
FAMILY LEAVE ALTHOUGH HAS
AFFECTS ON MATERNAL HEALTH.
BEING MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH AS
WELL AS HYSICAL HEALTH
EVIDENCE FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
SHOWS THAT PAID MATERNITY LEAVE
DECREASES THE NUMBER OF
INPATIENT HOSPITAL STAY IS
AMONG MOTHERS IN THE FIRST YEAR
OF THE CHILD'S LIFE THREE
DECREASE IN PREGNANCY RELATED
COMPLICATIONS SO PAID LEAVE IS
CRITICAL FOR THE RECOVERY OF
THE MOTHER AS WELL NOT ONLY FOR
BONDING WITH A NEW CHILD. AND
FINALLY ONE REALLY INTERESTING
PIECE OF NEW RESEARCH BY ONE OF
MY CO AUTHORS SUGGEST THAT
ACTUALLY WHEN YOU IMPLEMENT-
PAID PATERNITY LEAVE A AND THE
STUDY IS FROM SWEDEN WHEN
FATHERS CAN TAKE MORE TIME OFF
IT ACTUALLY IMPROVES MOTHER'S
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL HEALTH AS
WELL THE MOTHERS BENEFITS NOT
ON A FROM TIME AT HOME TO
RECOVER FROM CHILD BIRTH ONE OF
THEIR CHILD BUT ALSO FROM THIS
SUPPORT NETWORK THAT THEY GET.
WHEN A- PARENT UP THERE CAN.
THERE ARE QUITE A BIT OF
EVIDENCE ON THE EFFECTS OF
CALIFORNIA'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE
ON LABOR MARKET OUTCOMES- THERE
IS RATHER MIXED EVIDENCE ON THE
FX ON LONG TERM EMPLOYMENT AND
WAGE TRAJECTORIES OF MOTHERS.
SEVERAL PAPER SHALL WHEN
LOOKING AT CALIFORNIA'S PAID
FAMILY LEAVE OVER KIND OF A
LONGER HER RISE THEN THAT THERE
ARE POSITIVE EFFECTS ON
EMPLOYMENT AND SMALL POSITIVE
EFFECTS ON WAGES. HOWEVER A NEW
RECENT WORKING PAPER THAT USES
FEDERAL TAX DATA SHOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE
IS ASSOCIATED WITH- NEGATIVE
EFFECTS ON EMPLOYMENT AND WAGES
IN THE SHORT AND LONG TERM. ONE
IMPORTANT CAVEAT I THINK THAT
MAY EXPLAIN PART OF THOSE
DIFFERENCES THIS THAT IS. IS
THAT THIS NEW PAPER- ONLY LOOKS
AT AT MOTHER'S TO CLEAN IF YOU
BELIEVE IN THE FIRST QUARTER
THAT IT BECAME AVAILABLE WHO
GAVE BIRTH MADE A CLAIM. IN
JULY. SEPTEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
FOUR YOU MIGHT THINK THERE
ISN'T BELIEVE. EITHER THE
MOTHER OR TO LOOK UP LEAVE AS
SOON AS IT BECAME OF IT. A
WOULD BE SELECTED DIFFERENTLY
THAN THE AVERAGE MOTHER WHO
CLAIMS TODAY OR THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENTIAL- COSTS ARE STIGMAS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE LEAVE WHEN
IT WAS VERY FIRST INTRODUCED AS
OPPOSED TO TODAY- SO THAT'S
JUST ONE THING TO KEEP IN MIND
WHEN THINKING ABOUT THAT
RESULT. WE DON'T SEE ANY OF A
FAN- AVENUE ANY EVIDENCE OF
POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE EFFECTS-
ON EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES OUR
FATHERS BUT I WILL EMPHASIZE
TAKE UP IS QUITE LOW SO IT'S
MUCH HARDER TO IDENTIFY THE
FACTS. THE DURATION OF LEAVE
THAT FATHERS TAKE EVEN WHEN
THEY TAKE IT IS SO MUCH SHORTER
THAN IT IS FOR MOTHERS. AND
FINALLY WE'RE QUITE WORRIED
ABOUT AFFECTS ON FIRM- I THINK
THE LITERATURE SUGGESTS THAT
THERE ARE AT LEAST NON NEGATIVE
UP- AFFECTS ON THE PRODUCTIVITY
OR WAGE COSTS THAT FIRMS FACE
QUITE A BIT OF SURVEY EVIDENCE.
EXISTS NOW BUT SUGGEST THAT
FIRMS DO NOT VIEW THESE
POLICIES THAT'S COST AT LEAST
ONCE THEY'VE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED. THIS YEAR IS
ACTION FROM CALIFORNIA- USING A
MINUTE STRAIGHT OF DATA AND
SHOWS- IT JUST ON THE LEFT
ACCESS IN THE BLUE LINE- THE
PER EMPLOYEE WAGE COSTS OF
EMPLOYERS ON AVERAGE PLOTTED
AGAINST THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
TAKE UP RATES THE RED LINE IS-
FOR MOTHERS. AND YOU CAN SEE
THERE'S REALLY NO EVIDENCE THAT
WE EACH COST. INCREASE WHEN. IF
INTER. FINALLY ALL AND JUST
TALKING A BIT ABOUT SOME OF MY-
NEW RESEARCH WHICH SUGGESTS
THAT. HIGHER QUALITY FIRMS HAVE
CONSIDERABLY HIGHER CLEAN RATES
THAN LOWER QUALITY FIRMS AND
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
OVERALL I THINK PAID FAMILY
LEAVE APPEARS TO HAVE A QUITE
HIGH BENEFITS COMPARED TO ITS
COST. BUT WE NEED TO BE VERY
CAREFUL AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED
EARLIER IN THINKING ABOUT
BARRIERS TO TAKE UP AN EQUITY
IN ACCESS TO THIS LEAVE. MY
WORK ON FIRM QUALITY SUGGEST
THAT NOT ONLY DO HIGHER QUALITY
FIRMS HIRE LEAVE TAKING RATES
IN GENERAL. BUT THERE ARE
BETTER ABLE TO GET RID OF SOME
OF THIS INEQUALITY IN ACCESS OF
BY- WORKER- INCOME LEVEL OR
WORKER EARNINGS. SO WHAT THIS
FIGURE SHOWS IN THE BLUE BARS
IS THE IN THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS
BY WORKERS IN SCHOOL TELL EACH
25% OF THE EARNINGS
DISTRIBUTION SO ONE OF THE
LOWEST EARNERS AND FOUR IS THE
HIGHEST EARNERS BY FIRM. AND
THE RED BAR SHOW HOW MUCH THE
CLEAN- THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS IN
THE FIRM FOR EACH OF THESE
GROUPS WOULD GO UP. IF WE MOVED
ALL FIRMS TO BEING ONE STANDARD
DEVIATION HIGHER QUALITY AND SO
WHAT YOU CAN SEE HERE IS AGAIN
NOT ONLY ARE THE CLAIM RATES
FOR BETTER QUALITY FIRMS MUCH
HIGHER. BUT YOU GET RID OF A
LOT OF THE INEQUALITY IN ACCESS
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE LOWEST
EARNING WORKERS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THIS IS A
SHOULD BE TIME FOR QUESTIONS ON
THIS FIRST PANEL IF ANYONE HAS
ONE. BUT WE SIR WITH THE. I
HAVE A FOR SURE THIS OF.
CONVENING IS AN IT'S OKAY IF
YOU DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT YOU TO
HAVE TO KNOW LIKE ALL THE
STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN DONE
BUT- YOU KNOW WE- WE OBVIOUSLY
ARE TRYING TO GET TO TWELVE.
WEEKS IN CALIFORNIA. IS THERE-
ANY OUT OF THAT SUGGEST WHAT
THE ACTUAL IDEAL TIME AS I'M
ASSUME THAT. YOU KNOW THERE'S-
GOT TO BE. IT'S PROBABLY MORE
THAN TWELVE WEEKS DEFINITELY
MORE THAN WE HAVE NOW SIX WEEKS
EIGHT WEEKS. BUT AT SOME POINT
YOU KNOW WOMEN WHO WANT TO
REENTER THE ROOM FOR SOME STUFF
IS THERE ANY STUDY THAT
SUGGESTS WITH THAT IDEAL TIME
AS- THERE IS NOT A STUDY THAT
KIND OF CONCLUSIVELY SUGGESTS
WHAT AN IDEAL. STATION IS WHAT
I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT. A
POSITIVE HELD A FAX EMERGE
FAIRLY EARLY- BUT THAT'S NOT TO
SAY THERE AREN'T BIGGER HEALTH
EFFECTS IF YOU EXTEND. LEAVE
LONGER IN TERMS OF EMPLOYMENT
WHAT WE KNOW FROM EUROPE- SO
TAKE THIS WITH A LITTLE BIT OF
A GRAIN OF SALT BECAUSE EUROPE
AND THE UNITED STATES OF
PARTICULARLY THE SCANDINAVIAN
COUNTRIES IN THE UNITED STATES
ARE NOT DIRECTLY COMPATIBLE IN
MANY OTHER. WAYS BUT- WHAT WE
SEE FROM EUROPE IS THAT LEAVES
LONGER THAN ABOUT A YEAR. START
TO HAVE NEGATIVE EMPLOYMENT
CONSEQUENCE. WHERE LEAVE
SHORTER IN THE YEAR IN GENERAL
DO NOT HAVE NEGATIVE
EMPLOYMENT. QUINCES ARE LARGE
COSTS ON FIRMS TO THE BEST THAT
WE CAN IDENTIFY. IN THAT RANGE
FROM ABOUT THREE MONTHS TO A
YEAR WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A
SENSE OF WHAT THE IDEAL LIFE
AND NOT. AND ONE MORE QUESTION
SURE IT'S OKAY. WE TALKED ABOUT
THE WAGE CEILING ON WHAT THE
ONE HURT OR WHAT 1% WE'LL CALL
IT I KNOW THERE'S- 10% THE ONLY
WAY AND THAT- THAT WE'RE GIVING
AT THAT WE'RE TAKING FROM
PEOPLE'S PAYCHECK BASICALLY TO
FUND THIS PROGRAM CALIFORNIA'S
THAT YOU SAID ABOUT ONE
EIGHTEEN SOME STATES GO UP TO
ONE THIRTY THREE IS THAT THE
HIGHEST HAS ANYONE SUGGESTED. I
MEAN IF YOU WANT A PROGRESSIVE
APPROACH THAT SEEMS LIKE WE
COULD GO TO ONE FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS WITHOUT MUCH OF FACT
WRECKED SO I WOULD KNOW THAT
THE DESERT OF COLUMBIA IT
ACTUALLY DOES NOT HAVE A WAGE
CEILING. ON THEIR PROGRAM AND
THEN THE STATE'S WITH ONE
THIRTY THREE THAT'S ACTUALLY
THE UNTOUCHABLE WAGE BASE FOR
SOCIAL SECURITY. SO SOME STATES
HAVE JUST PASTED ACTION UP WITH
ADEQUATE. THAT WILL NOTE THAT
THE GOVERNORS OF. COMMITTEE ON
THE ISSUE HAS BROUGHT UP THIS
ISSUE AND TAKING A LOOK LOOK AT
IT. THEIR FORTUNES SIDE OF HIS
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF WORKERS UP
IN THAT STRATA. AND SO THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S
COLLECTED HE DOESN'T. PAY FOR A
WHOLE LOT OF BENEFIT. OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. WELL
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU- MADAM
CHAIR AND MADAM CHAIR FOR
HOSTING THIS HEARING AND I
THINK THIS IS MY SECOND
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN A
SELECT COMMITTEE AND GREAT TO
BE HERE IN MY DISTRICT AND SEE
MY CONSTITUENTS THAT TESTIFYING
US OF UP AND SINGER OUR DOCTOR
FROM UC DAVIS THE BIG PICTURE
I'M OF OPTICS SUPPORTER OF THIS
AS YOU SAID IT'S YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY. BENEFICIAL TO-
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN'S HEALTH
AND THE WORK FORCE I THINK A
STABLE WORKFORCE THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY TALK ABOUT TOO MUCH
BUT YOU KNOW IT'S HARD FOR
EMPLOYERS TO GET ON STAY ON IT
SO HAVING A STABLE WORKFORCE IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SO I GET
ALL THAT THANKS FOR LETTING US
OF A I HAVE TWO ISSUES I WANT
TO FOCUS ON SO FIRST. THE STATE
IT SAID THIS IS A PUBLIC
PRIVATE. SO YOU. STATE OVERSEAS
AT. THE SAME BENEFITS ARE FOR
PEOPLE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
AND THE PUBLIC- HAS THIS. WE
KNOW THAT STATE AGENCIES. VERY
FEW PEOPLE HERE IN THE CAPITAL
KNOW THAT THE STATE SENATE'S
LIKE THE ENVY OF. STATE
WORKFORCE IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
BENEFICIAL TO BE YES. STATE
SENATOR STATE ASSEMBLY
LEGISLATIVE STAFF MEMBER. THE
TIME YOU HAVE TO. BOND WITH
YOUR NEWBORN VERY VERY
GENEROUS. SO WHAT HAS THE STATE
DOWN TO YOU KNOW MY DISTRICT
HAS PLENTY OF STATE WORKERS.
YOU KNOW. TENS OF THOUSANDS SO
WHAT DO WE DO TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE. SOME UNIFORMITY IN THAT
AMONG THE STATE AGENCIES.
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO. AS WE
LOOK AT. EXPANSION AND FOR ALL
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW
WHAT WE NEED TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE
YOU KNOW WHAT TIMES. PEOPLE SAY
WELL YOU PASSED LAWS IN PASSED
UPON NOT. WHAT ARE YOU DOING
CALIFORNIA.TO STEP IT UP AND
BY EXAMPLE. SOME COULD DRESS UP
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. LOW ONE
THOUSAND BARGAIN FOR- THE RIGHT
TO STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
UNPAID LEAVE US AN EXTENSION OF
THAT. I CAN'T REMEMBER THE
EXACT YEAR- AND THAT CONCLUDES
THE- VAST MAJORITY OF STATE
EMPLOYEES THERE OTHER
BARGAINING UNITS WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT. I THAT HAVE NOT
BARGAINED FOR- THAT BENEFIT-
AND SO THEY DON'T RECEIVE THE
BENEFIT- WHAT I WILL TELL YOU
CONTRACT ISSUE NOT A- STATE
POLICY EXACTLY RIGHT IN THE LAW
THAT ALLOWS- ALL PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES TO BARGAIN. OF FOR
THAT I THINK THAT THERE WAS A
LEGISLATION. EARLIER LAST
EARLIER THIS YEAR- THAT SPOKE
TO TEACHERS AND THEIR ABILITY
TO GOT IT AND IT'S LEFT OPEN
TO- THEIR BARGAINING ABILITY-
TO REAP BE ABLE TO RECEIVE THAT
BENEFIT. AT THE STATEWIDE LEVEL
I'M EXCITED TO SAY THAT- STATE
SUPERVISORS FINALLY HAVE A NOT
EXACTLY- WHAT- STI AND PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROVIDE- BUT WERE
NOW- SUPERVISORS ABLE TO GET-
AT LEAST PARTIAL WAGE
REPLACEMENT FOR TIME OFF. OF
FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE SO WE
HAVE TAKEN JUST RECENTLY SOME
STEPS TOWARDS A- BUT IT'S A
VERY MUCH LEFT UP TO THE
INDIVIDUAL BARGAINING UNITS TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT THE
WORKERS- ON HOW THEY WANT TO-
READ WHETHER NOT THEY WANT TO
RECEIVE THIS BENEFIT OR NOT.
THE SECOND QUESTION IS IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO FORD WE WEREN'T
THE LEADER IN THIS AND AS YOU
SEE FROM THE CHART. OTHER
STATES HAVE HAVE STEPPED UP AND
SURPASSED OUR OUR OUR TIME
FRAME THERE WE HAVE LEGISLATORS
PUSH THE ENVELOPE FOR ALL ALL
ALL WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA. SO
HAVE WE EVER AS A STATE THOUGHT
ABOUT HEY WELL YOU KNOW YOU
KNOW YOU COULD DO A BILL INSIDE
SOMETHING A LOT STATUE THAT.
EVERYBODY BUT WHAT ABOUT. THE
STATE WORK FORCE HAS THAT EVER
BEEN ON THE TABLE. I HAVE I DO
NOT KNOW OF A- SINGLE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT'S BEEN ON- THE
TABLE. OF BECAUSE IT'S A
BARGAIN MOBILE RIGHT I THINK
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERN
ABOUT- UNION- RIGHTS AND- RIGHT
AROUND WHAT IS COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN WHAT IS NOT
COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN- BUT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE I HAVE NOT SEEN IT. I
WOULD ALSO BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T SAY THAT WHILE DURATION
IS ONE OF THE FACTORS THAT GOES
INTO THIS BENEFIT. THERE ARE
LOTS OF OTHER. PARTS AND
PARCELS AGAIN A STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE IS A FIFTY
TWO WEEK LONG TEMPORARY
DISABILITY INSURANCE BENEFITS.
AND WHILE IT DOES NOT INCLUDE.
FUNDING IS USE FOR BIRTH
MOTHERS- GENERALLY AFTER ABOUT
TEN WEEKS BUT CAN BE USE FOR
MUCH LONGER PERIOD OF TIME. AND
THAT'S A MUCH BETTER BENEFIT-
THEN I. THINK JUST ABOUT ANY
OTHER STATE THAT I'VE SEEN. SO
WHEN. LOOKING AT THIS BENEFIT
IN PARTICULAR WHEN IT COMES TO-
CHILDBIRTH I DO BELIEVE THAT
YOU NEED TO TAKE A LOOK- AS
RIGHTLY POSED BY THE COMMITTEE
AS WELL AS- A SOME OF THE OTHER
FOLKS TESTIFYING. THAT YOU LOOK
AT OTHER THINGS SUCH AS- THE
WORKERS RIGHT AROUND IT- AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT YOU RECEIVE
ANOTHER- BENEFITS THAT ARE
SOON. AS WELL AS THE AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE THAT CAN USE IT. AND IF
IT THE TORAH WITH THE
COMMITTEE- DOCTOR STERN BROUGHT
UP ONE ISSUE AROUND A
PARTICULARLY WOMEN RETURNING TO
THE WORK PLACE THAT I. I'D LIKE
TO JUST PUT AN UNDERLINED AND-
IN OUR SOCIETY IN THE UNITED
STATES WE HAVE MORE WOMEN THAN
EVER. THAT ARE PHD IS WE HAVE A
HIGHER ACCEPTANCE RATE AMONG
WOMEN THAN THAT. BUT THESE ARE
THE EXACT TYPES OF PEOPLE ONLY
TALK ABOUT OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
SOCIETY. WE WANT TO ENSURE
DON'T HAVE THAT LARGE BREAK-
WHEN IT COMES TO. OF THE
ECONOMY BECAUSE JUST AS THE
DOCTOR SAID WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE BROUGHT
BACK. AND WE FEEL THEIR FULL
ECONOMIC FRUITION- IN OUR
ECONOMY. THANK YOU THEN CHRIS
AND I HAVE A QUESTION A MONDAY
THE STATE'S THE TO GO TO TWELVE
YES WELL WEEKS. IS THAT IS AS A
UNIFORM AND HOW THAT'S. PAID
FOR ABOVE AND BEYOND WE DO AS
FAR AS THAT. YOU KNOW THAT
PAYROLL TAX VERSES. HE HE IN
THE PLAYER TAX VERSES THE
INDIVIDUAL OR THE THIS IS
STATE. PAY SOME OF THAT TOO
WHEN THEY DID THE EXPANSION SO
IT REALLY VARIES BY STATE BUT
IT'S EITHER ALL EMPLOYEE FUNDED
LIKE CALIFORNIA OR COMBINATION
OF EMPLOYEE AND- EMPLOYER
FUNDED PROGRAMS. AND IS THE
STATE ANY OTHER STATES STEP UP
AND DEPEND ON THEIR GENERAL
FUND IT'S ALL BASED UPON THE
MODEL FOR THE. BASICALLY YES
BUT THIS WOMAN IN A- DESOLATE
DIDN'T DIDN'T SAY WE DID
RECEIVEADDITIONAL ALLOCATIONS
OF THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND TO
DO THE OUTRAGE. AND THAT'S THE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS NIGHT OF
MONEY COMING OUT OF. TO BE
CLEAR IT IS THIS AD IN RESPONSE
THAT LAST QUESTION. IS THE
MONEY DOES THE MONEY COME FROM
STATE GENERAL FUNDS WERE
EMPLOYERS AS WELL AS EMPLOYEES
SO WHEN SPEAKING OF A BENEFITS
SPECIFICALLY NOT SO MUCH FOR
OUT RETURN MINISTRATION. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
FUNDING IS COMING FROM EITHER
EMPLOYEES ONLY OR ALSO
EMPLOYEES. AND EMPLOYERS
DEPENDING ON THE STATE. AND
THEN LASTLY THAT THE TAKE
OPERATE FOR EITHER. THE DOCTOR
THE ADMISSIONS TO AS FAR AS
PEOPLE ON LOW WAGE POSITIONS
WHO ARE IN THE SERVICE INDUSTRY
IT'S EASY TO UNDERSTAND FOR IF
YOU HAVE A FULL TIME JOB FOR
THE STATE TO WORK FOR. IN OUR
BUSINESS ARE COMING FROM WHAT
HAVE YOU BUT- SOME OF THE JOBS
IN CALIFORNIA. LOW WEIGHTS NOT
QUITE FULL TIME MULTIPLE JOBS
AND SO. IS IT JUST REALLY
COMPLICATED FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IS IT. IS IT.
YOU'RE NOT. A UNIFORM IN THAT.
IN THE- APPLICABILITY OF THAT.
THERE IS DIFFERENT
PARTICIPATION RATES AS YOU AS
WE SAW RIGHT SO HOW DO WE
ATTRIBUTE THAT AND WHAT WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO ADDRESS THAT.
WHAT A MARKET RESEARCH REPORT
THAT WAS COMMISSIONED BY THE
PLYMOUTH DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT
MANY. WORKERS INDICATED THAT
JOB PROTECTIONS FOR A BARRIER
TO ACCESSING PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
AS WELL AS THE WAY TO PLACEMENT
RATES NOW THIS REPORT WAS DONE.
A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO AND IT
WAS DONE ACTUALLY BEFORE WE
BOOSTED THE RATES FOR VERY LOW
WAGE WORKERS. AS THE DIRECTOR
IT INDICATED WE ARE SEEING AN
INCREASE AND TAKE UP RATES- SO
I THINK THOSE TWO BARRIERS ARE
VERY. THE VERY IMPORTANT TO
CONSIDER WHEN THINKING ABOUT
LOWER WAGE WORKERS IN
PARTICULAR THEY ALSO THINK. JOB
PROTECTIONS AND THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE FOUR. LAWS UNDER
WHICH A WORKER COULD HAVE JOB
PROTECTED LEAVE IS PROBABLY
REALLY CONFUSING FOR EVERY
WORKER. AND OFTEN TIMES EVERY
LEGISLATORS AT WHAT EXACTLY I
WOULD NOTE THAT THAT WE HAVE A
TABLE IN THE REPORT THAT TRIES
TO LAY OUT THE COMPLEXITY OF
THOSE THINK SENDING. AN
ASTRONAUT TO THE MOON HAD A
SIMPLER FLOW CHART THEN ARE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. I JUST WANT TO
NOTE. **** THOUGHT THAT- WE
CONSISTENTLY MOVE UP THE
MINIMUM WAGE IN AND WE ARE
WORKING TO GET IT TO A LIVABLE
WAGE IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
PROBABLY NOT EVEN LEVEL ONCE
WE- REACH FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR BUT- TO SUGGESTED A SINGLE
MOM WHO MAKES MINIMUM WAGE CAN
SUDDENLY LIVE. IN A MORE
EXPENSIVE TIME WITH THE CHILD
WE ALL KNOW THE COST OF
CHILDREN I DON'T GET ME STARTED
DIAPERS. YOU WERE ASKING HER TO
LIVE ON 70% OF OUR SALARY
HAPPENING. IT'S JUST NOT. LIKE
A LOT OF US SO I AND I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IF I MAKE. THE
STUDIES INDICATED THEIR THEIR-
OLDER STUDIES WHILE AGAIN.
RACHEL PROVING AND- THE MORE
CHOP PROTECTION I THINK DOES
HELP BUT WITHOUT IT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. FOR OUR LOW INCOME
WORKERS WHO CAN BARELY MAKE IT
ON WHAT THEY'VE GOT CLEARLY
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO BE. AT
WHEN I CAN SEE THE KIND OF-
ADJUSTMENTS IN ACCESSING THIS
NOW THAT IS THOUGH. PRIMARILY
FOR- PAID FAMILY LEAVE FOR
NEWBORNS IN CARING FOR YOUNG
ONES. WE ARE GOING TO HAVE SOME
SPEAK ON CARING FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS BUT I'D LIKE IF YOU
WILL. IF YOU DONE ANY RESEARCH
ON THIS TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT. THE CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH PEOPLE TAKING
CARE OF THEIR AGING OR AGING
STATE- AS SOME OF US. ARE
AGING. NOT ALL OF US BUT SOME
OF US WITH GRAY HAIR
RECOGNIZING LOOKING IN A MIRROR
SOMEDAY THAT BE ME AND THAT
SOMEDAY COULD BE. RATHER THAN.
THAT BEING SAID- WE DON'T YOU
KNOW OUR OUR CARE FOR SENIORS
IS APPALLING CAR NURSING HOMES
AND OPTIONS AVAILABLE FOR
PEOPLE NEED CARE. SO WE EXPECT
PEOPLE TO CARE FOR THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS HOW WE GONNA DO THAT.
AND STILL BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
OUR- OF ABILITY TO CARE FOR
OURSELVES AND PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLES FOR OURSELVES AND OUR
FAMILIES. WHAT WHAT IS THIS
LOOK LIKE FOR THEM. SENATOR I
APPRECIATED IF YOU WILL LET ME
HAVE A SHAMELESS PLUG FOR THE
GOVERNOR I'M VERY HONORED TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO. WORK ON
THIS PROGRAM- AND SERVE
GOVERNOR NEWSOME AS HE TRIES TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
YESTERDAY HE JUST A- LARGE
HEARING ON ALZHEIMER'S ONE OF
THE- RESULT OF SOME OF THE
AGENT. WHAT WE SEE- DIFFERENT
FROM- PAID FAMILY FOR BABY
BONDING- IS THAT- FOLKS THAT
UTILIZES BENEFIT OR USE AYE
UTILIZING IT MUCH DIFFERENT- IN
SO INSTEAD OF. A CONSISTENT
PATTERN OVER A FOUR WEEKS JUST
YOU HAVE A SOLID FOUR WEEKS
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IS. OF
PEOPLE TAKING ONE DAY HERE ONE
DAY THERE AND- AND A TOTALLY
WHAT WE'RE TOLD IS BECAUSE
THAT'S DIFFERENT APPOINTMENTS
AS PEOPLE- ACCESS DIFFERENT
PARTS OF CARE- IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF LIFE OR FRANKLY-
LIFETIME MOMENTS- IN OUR-
CAMPAIGN AND OUTREACH EFFORTS
WE ARE. DEFINITELY NOT LEAVING
THAT'LL ON- I THINK IT IS I'M
LOOKING AT YOUR CHICHI THERE
BUT I THINK IT'S RHODE ISLAND-
WHO REALLY FOCUSED ON ELDER
CARE. OF FROM THE START OF
THEIR PROGRAM- FRANKLY I THINK
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE LACK FUND
WE HAD TO DO- FOR OUTRAGE WE
REACHED OUT TO A LOT OF THE
HOSPITALS TALK TO THEM ABOUT.
BENEFIT TO- NEW PERSON
FATHER'S. INITIALLY UP BUTTON
HONESTLY. I TO TAKE IT APART.
THE OF MONEY THAT'S BEEN
APPROPRIATED TO THE DEPARTMENT
MOVING FORWARD. AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO AND- I'LL REACH. TWO
TYPICALLY TO THE FOLKS THAT ARE
IN THE CARE AND MAKE. SURE THAT
THEY KNOW THAT THAT'S THERE
pOF THOSE GROUPS BECAUSE THERE
AREN'TAS MANY FRANKLY AS
ESTABLISHED AS I'D LIKE TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE. A RP
DOES A WONDERFUL JOB AND THEY
ARE A GOOD PARTNER IN BUT IT'S
A LITTLE HARDER TO PIN DOWN THE
ADVOCACY GROUPS- FOR PEOPLE
LOOKING OF CARE BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT- WE ARE
DEFINITELY LOOKING TO INCREASE
THE UTILIZATION AROUND. WELL AS
THE AUTHOR THE BILL TO EXPAND
NEW BABY BONDING I HOPE THAT WE
ARE GOING TO ROB FROM PETER TO
PAY PAUL THAT WE'RE GOING TO
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO DO THESE
PROGRAMS- COLLABORATIVELY AND
NOT. START COMPETING FOR THOSE
DOLLARS SO- I'M WONDERING ARE
THERE IT TO ARE THERE ANY
STATISTICS ON THE IMPACTS OF
CARING FOR FAMILY MEMBERS. ON
EMPLOYMENT ON EMPLOYEES VERSUS
EMPLOYERS IN TERMS OF. THEIR
THEIR ABILITY TO EARN
SUFFICIENT FUNDS THE- EMPLOYERS
HAVING EMPLOYEES WHO WERE
TAKING THAT KIND OF TIME
OFFICER BEEN ANY DATA IS FOR
ANY. ANY ANY STUDY DONE ON THIS
ISSUE. I DON'T BELIEVE SO AT
THIS POINT BUT WHAT I WILL TELL
YOU IS THAT- I'M MORE THAN
HAPPY TO- ASK MISTER WASHINGTON
COULD BUT TO GET BACK TO YOUR
OFFICE SENATOR OR THE COMMITTEE
IF YOU FALL PLEASE- ON OUR-
RATES AND THE DATA THAT WE DO
COLLECT AROUND BOND- SKEWS ME
CARE GIVER. I JUST THINK AGAIN
WITH CALIFORNIA AGING AS IT IS.
WE'VE GOT TO BE REALISTIC FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE YOU MENTION
ARE PHD IS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
FAMILIES. AND WE OF WOMEN FOR
PRIMARILY HAVE BEEN VIEWED AS
AND TAKEN THE ROLE OF CARE
GIVER AND- WE DON'T WANT- IT
AGAIN FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE TO
MAKE THESE VERY VERY DIFFICULT
HOBSON'S CHOICES. SOPHIE'S
CHOICE IS ACTUALLY ON HOW TO
CARE FOR THE PEOPLE THEY LOVE
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO BE GOOD EMPLOYEES
AND GOOD WORKERS AND-
SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR CAREERS SO.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
INITIAL- ON AUTHOR OF SENATOR
KEWL. SUPERVISOR COOL- DESIGNED
FOR THE PROGRAM FOR IS THIS NOT
JUST FOR ONE INSTANCE IN LIFE-
BUT IT IS FOR A LIFETIME. OF IN
INCIDENCES AND IT IS A- IN
INSURANCE PROGRAM THAT A SOCIAL
WELFARE PROGRAM FOR WORKERS. I
THINK THAT'S A GOOD DISTINCTION
I DO HAVE A WONDER TO OTHER
QUESTIONS. YOU KNOW WE KNOW THE
BENEFITS OF FAMILY LEAVE
WHETHER IT'S FOR CARE GIVING
FOR SENIORS WHETHER TO BABY
PLANNING I'M WONDERING ARE YOU
SEEING MORE EMPLOYERS OFFERING
THESE KINDS OF FAMILY THE
BENEFITS ON THEIR OWN- OR IN
ADDITION TO WHAT CALIFORNIA
PROVIDES IN COULD YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. WHO THEY ARE
AND WHAT. THE RESULTS HAVE BEEN
OR WHAT IS INSPIRED THEM TO DO
THIS. ANYTHING THAT YOU CAN
ADDRESS. SO I CAN'T SPEAK TO
CALIFORNIA HERE'S AS
SPECIFICALLY BUT OVERALL- IN
THE U. S. IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS. EMPLOYER PROVIDED PAID
FAMILY LEAVE HAS GONE UP
CONSIDERABLY IT'S STILL QUITE
LOW- TODAY ABOUT 20% OF ALL
WORKERS HAVE ACCESS TO EITHER.
EMPLOYER PROVIDED MATERNITY OR
PATERNITY LEAVE. CHARLES WHAT
PROVIDED EMPLOYER EMPLOYER
PROVIDED YES- SO THAT'S GONE UP
FROM LIKE TWELVE PERCENT- YOU
KNOW A DECADE AGO SO IT'S A BIG
INCREASE BUT IT'S STILL QUITE
LOW- IN CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS
ARE ALLOWED TO TOP OFF YOUR-
YOUR WAGE REPLACEMENT THAT THE
STATE PROVIDES. TO MY KNOWLEDGE
THERE'S NO GOOD DATA ON HOW
MANY- HOW MANY EMPLOYERS CHOOSE
TO DO THAT OR YOU SAY OP OFF
WHAT IS THAT MEANS SO-
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM WILL PAY
60% OF YOUR BASE WAGE. YOUR
EMPLOYER CAN TOP THAT UP TO A
100% OF WHAT YOU WOULD GET SO
YOU CAN'T BE PAID- MORE THAN
YOU WOULD BE IF YOU WERE JUST
OUT WORK BUT THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
IT TO MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE-
MAYBE YOU KNOW BACK. I HAVEN'T
SEEN ANYTHING ON ON HOW COMMON
THAT IS. I WOULD SAY IT'S LOW
INCOME AND WE DO HAVE SOME SELF
INSURANCE. OF PROGRAMS THAT WE
CAN GIVE YOU STATISTICS ON IT
IS A VERY LOW NUMBER THE COST
OF INSURANCE IS- OFTENTIMES
VERY HIGH BECAUSE THE- THE AS I
DESCRIBE THE PROGRAM IS AN
INSURANCE PROGRAM SO THE POOL.
IS A LOT SMALLER SO THE RISK IS
A LOT HIGHER OF FOR THOSE
COMPANIES BUT WE DO HAVE AND
KEEP RECORDS OF THOSE.
COMPANIES I'D BE REMISS IF I
DID NOT KNOW THAT- I BELIEVE LA
CITY IS ON ITS WAY TO BUT SAN
FRANCISCO- CITY DID PASS AN
ORDINANCE ALLOWING FOR. I
BELIEVE IT'S UP 290% OF WAIT
REPLACEMENT- THAT THE- CITY
MANDATES ALL EMPLOYERS MAKE UP
THE DIFFERENCE FOR. OKAY WELL A
LAST QUESTION- AND THAT REALLY
NEED TO DO BETTER FEW. XIN OF
HOW WE COULD GO ABOUT BOTH FOR-
NEW BOOK NEW IN A BABY BONDING
AND AS WELL AS FAMILY LEAVE A
COUPLE THINGS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED WERE SOME OF THE
OPTIONS AN EMPLOYER CON
CONTRIBUTED FUND WHICH FOR
STATES TO TAXABLE WAGE FUND
INCREASED THE UPPER LEVELS BUT
IS POINTED OUT THERE AREN'T
THAT MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING
A THAT OF- INCOME THAT. WOULD
CONTRIBUTE AND THEN. AGAIN THE
INCREASING CONTRIBUTION RATE
WHICH IS FOR AGGRESSIVE AND I
THINK THAT WOULD REALLY
UNDERMINE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FOR A PARTICULAR LOW AND MIDDLE
INCOME PEOPLE SO. ARE ANY
INCENTIVES THAT WE COULD DO FOR
EMPLOYERS TO GET THEM ON BOARD.
IN A WE CAN THERE'S AN EASY WAY
AND HARD WAY TO DO THIS AND TO-
OBVIOUSLY EMPLOYERS ARE NOT.
SEEING OR YOU KNOW NEED TO DO
MORE AND DO BETER TO SEE THE
BENEFITS MAYBE WE NEED TO DO
BETTER TO. SHOW THEM WHAT THOSE
BENEFITS ARE- BUT BUT ARE THERE
ANY SOLUTION SO YOU CAN SEE AND
CAN SUGGEST. SO I THINK.
THINKING ABOUT WHAT FIRMS ARE
DOING OR WHAT FIRMS ARE NOT
DOING IN ENCOURAGING LEAVE
TAKING AND WHAT BENEFITS
THEY'RE INDEPENDENTLY PROVIDING
IS REALLY IMPORTANT I HAVE TO
SAY FROM A RESEARCH STANDPOINT
WE JUST DON'T KNOW A WHOLE LOT
ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY IT IS THAT
THESE GOOD FIRMS ARE DOING OR
THESE HIGH TAKE UP FIRMS ARE
DOING. BUT UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S
GOING ON IS REALLY IMPORTANT
WHEN THINKING ABOUT NOT ONLY
CAN WE FIND WAYS TO MAKE THESE
THESE PROGRAMS MORE SUSTAINABLE
IN TERMS OF COST BUT ALSO IN
TERMS OF THINKING ABOUT- ACT SO
EVEN IF WE HAVE JOB PROTECTION
EAT IF WE HAVE A REPLACEMENT
RATE. IF EMPLOYER MAKES IT
DIFFICULT. TO TAKE EITHER
THROUGH- YOU'RE GOING TO GET A
SIGNED A BAD SCHEDULE OR YOU'RE
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET
PROMOTED OR- YOU KNOW
TECHNICALLY I CAN'T FIRE YOU
BUT I'M GONNA MAKE IT REALLY
UNPLEASANT FOR YOU TO COME BACK
TO WORK. IF THESE SORTS OF
THINGS ARE OF CONCERN TO
WORKERS WE'RE NOT GOING TO SEE
IT TAKE UP RATES THAT- ARE
COMPATIBLE TO WHAT WE WOULD
EXPECT. FROM OTHER- OTHER
COUNTRIES AND OTHER STATES AND
SO I THINK WE NEED TO THINK
VERY CAREFULLY ABOUT WHAT WE
CAN LEARN FROM EMPLOYERS THAT
WE KNOW ARE DOING A GOOD JOB ON
WORK FAMILY BALANCE NOW WE SEE
A LOT OF LARGE EMPLOYERS. THAT
ARE REALLY USING THAT EXISTENCE
A VERY GENEROUS PAID PARENTAL
LEAVE PROGRAMS- AND OTHER PAID
LEAVE FAMILY FRIENDLY PROGRAMS
AS A WAY TO RECRUIT HIGH
QUALITY HIGH SKILLED WORKERS.
AND ALSO AS A WAY TO CREATE A
POSITIVE IMAGE WITH THE PUBLIC
IN GENERAL AS PUBLIC SUPPORT
FOR THESE PROGRAMS RISES. BUT
THERE HASN'T BEEN ANY RESEARCH
ON THAT BUT WE'RE JUST KIND OF
STARTING TO TRY AND THINK ABOUT
HOW WE IDENTIFY THE SPECIFIC
ASPECTS ABOUT WHAT FIRMS ARE
DOING I THINK THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL. AGAIN AGAIN AS
YOU SAY IF COMPANIES DON'T WANT
TO PARTICIPATE THEY'LL MAKE
LIKE DIFFICULT FOR EMPLOYEES
AND THE- BLESSING OF SOMEONE
WANTS TO DO WHEN THEY'RE COMING
BACK FROM A- PERIOD OF LEAVE IS
TO BE GIVEN A PINK SLIP THE DAY
THEY COME BACK AND IT'S A FEAR
THAT. WE KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE AND- RIGHTLY SO- SO. I
WOULD HOPE THAT THIS MIGHT BE
SOMETHING WE COULD LOOK AT IT
DOES. IT'S A WIN WIN- BUT IT WE
NEED TO DEMONSTRATE THAT SOME
HOUSE SO THAT IT ISN'T JUST AN
ANECDOTAL AS I MENTIONED MY- MY
FRIENDS OVER PATAGONIA THEIR
OTHER COMPANIES I'M SURE TO DO
THIS. BUT THE YOU KNOW LEADING
BY EXAMPLE IN IN DEMONSTRATING
THAT THIS IS POSSIBLE I THINK
WOULD BE. OF CRITICAL VALUE TO
US. HE WON'T HAVE A LAST WORD
DIRECOR HEADING BUT NO OF. THE
BUT I WILL. IF YOU TAKE THE
LAST WORD. SENATOR I WOULD SET
TELL YOU THAT- WASHINGTON
STATE. HAS CREATED A PROGRAM IN
THE SENATE PROGRAM FOR
BUSINESSES AS WELL AS- A NEW
YORK STATE. THERE A PRIVATE.
PRIVATE SYSTEM DIFFERENT THAN
OUR PUBLIC SYSTEM- FOR PAID
LEAVE SO IT'S SO IT'S DIFFERENT
THERE- AND I KNOW THAT- THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMITTEE HAS
DEFINITELY TAKEN A LOOK AT A-
TIME- UNEMPLOYMENT RATES- TO
THIS AND LOOKING AT AND-
POSSIBLE BENEFIT- TO EMPLOYERS
USING THAT TYPE OF THE SYSTEM
BUT- NOTHING CONCRETE PROSTATE
AS OF YET BUT THERE ARE SOME.
EXCITING PROGRAMS I THINK TO
YOUR POINT TO TRY TO
INCENTIVIZE. ARE GOOD EMPLOYERS
A TO COME ALONG. THANK YOU AND
I HOPE. JUST TO RESPOND THE
THAT WE KNOW LAW THAT WE THAT
WE HAVE SOME KIND OF A UNIFORM
SYSTEM HERE SO THAT. PEOPLE
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
EMPLOYERS KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO DO. SO THAT WILL I
THINK THAT ALSO WILL HELP
PEOPLE ACCESS THE PROGRAM WHEN
THERE'S LESS CONFUSION. ANY
OTHER THOUGHTS OR COMMENTS OR
SHOULD WE SAY. THANK YOU TO
THIS PANEL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR. YOUR INSIGHTS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU. A NUMBER OF YOU I
QUESTIONS OF MR HENNING X. SOME
POINT TODAY I'LL CALL YOU. OF
YEAH YOU'RE NOT GONNA LOVE IT.
CONSTANT DESIRE. TO FIX
EVERYTHING SO NOW WE'RE GOING
TO BRING UP ALL THEIR SECOND
THIRD PANELS TOGETHER RAN START
WITH A- FIRST HAND ACCOUNT FROM
SERRA L. ABOUT ACTUALLY TAKING
PAID FAMILY LEAVE- ROSS GONNA
HAVE JENNA GARY SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL AID AT WORK
MUCH STEIGER THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION DR DONNA BATON THE
RESEARCH ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR
FOR. KAREN TAUGHT LOGY AT THE
UNIVERSITY SON CALIFORNIA
ANJANEYA CASSIDY THE DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION IN THAT ORDER I'M
SORRY AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE ARE
ABOUT FORTY EIGHT MINUTES- SO I
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE BUT I'M GOING
TO. BE KIND OF TIGHT. SIX I
WILL GO IS SIX I'M SORRY IF YOU
THOUGHT WAS SEVEN AND IF YOU
SEE ME RUNNING COMMITTEE I
ACTUALLY TAKE THAT REALLY
SERIOUSLY SO I DON'T WANT TO
YOU WANT TO BE OFFENDED. WE'LL
START WITH SERRA. GOOD MORNING
LADIES I AM MY NAME IS THERE
THE MOTHER OF THREE. AND. I
HAVE TWO OLDER CHILDREN AND ONE
TODDLER. AM I BECAME PREGNANT
LATER IN LIFE OBVIOUSLY. AND
AFTER A DIVORCE AND
ESTABLISHING MYSELF AND A WELL
LOVED AND FILLING CAREER. HOW.
I SPENT TWO YEARS HONING MY
SKILLS. CLIMBING THE RANKS TO
BECOME THE HEAD OF MY
DEPARTMENT. MY LIFE WAS GOING
WELL. I OWN MY OWN HOME I HAD A
GOOD JOB A CAREER THAT WAS
FILLING SOMETHING THAT I CAN
POUR MY HEART INTO AND FEEL
LIKE I WAS. GIVING TO MAKING
UNIT COMMUNITY. MY WIFE IS
GETTING BACK ON TRACK AFTER A
TOUGH DIVORCE. I MET MY PARTNER.
AN EXPECTEDLY BECAME PREGNANT.
THIS CREATED A HARDSHIP AS I
WAS THE MAIN MAJOR. STE. MY JOB
WAS ONLY A SUPPORTIVE AS THEY
WERE OBLIGATED TO BE. I HAD
MANY COMPLICATIONS. TING
PRETERM LABOR STARTING AT FIVE
MONTHS. AND. BEFORE BEING
PLACED ON IT MEDICAL LEAVE I
HAD DISCUSSED MAY RETURN WITH
MY EMPLOYER THEY WE WERE ALL IN
AGREEMENT THAT TEMPORARY PART
TIME WOULD BE A GOOD PLACE AND
UPON MY RETURN. GIVE ME A
CHANCE TO EASE BACK INTO THE
RIGOROUS JOB I LOVED. ALL WAS
WELL OR SO IT SEEMED. MY
DELIVERY WENT WELL.
UNFORTUNATELY MY BABY HAD
COMPLICATIONS. SHE HAD AN A. L.
T. E A LIFE THREATENING EVENT
SHE ALMOST DIED. SHE'S IN THE
NECK YOU FOR THREE WEEKS. I TOO
WAS SUFFERING AN INFECTION AND
POST PARTUM DEPRESSION. PARTLY
DUE TO THE STRESS MY EMPLOYER
WAS NO PLACING ON ME THEY
WANTED ME TO RETURN AT SIX
WEEKS AND MY BODY WAS NO WHERE
NEAR HE'LL- I JUST NEEDED TIME.
THAT THEY WERE UNFORTUNATELY
UNWILLING TO GIVE. MAY PLEASE
FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE WAS
REJECTED A TOTAL OF THREE TIMES.
USE THE EXCUSE THAT THERE WERE
SMALL BUSINESS. TECHNICALLY
THEY WERE ONE PERSON SHY. THE
LOSS AT THAT TIME. WITH THAT
CAME RETALIATION AND HEARD
Y'ALL TALKING ABOUT THAT. I WAS
DEMOTED. IN THE OFFER PART TIME
WAS RESCINDED. THEY DEMANDED I
RETURN AT FULL TIME AT FULL
CAPACITY OR BE FIRED. INCLUDED
TWELVE HOUR DAYS SOMETIMES SIX
DAYS A WEEK PERFORMING ARDUOUS
LABOR THAT INCLUDED HEAVY
LIFTING AND LONG HOURS ON MY
FEET. I WAS LEFT WITH THE
BROKEN BODY IN A HELPLESS BABY
I CONTINUOUS OXYGEN MONITORS.
SHE WOULD NEED SPECIALIZED CARE
IN A MEDICAL SETTING. THE ONLY
SUCH DAY CARE WAS LOGICALLY AND
FINANCIALLY UNATTAINABLE.
FILLING LOS HOPELESS I TURNED
TO MY DOCTOR. HE AGREED THAT
THE UNDUE STRESS THAT MY JOB IN
CARING FOR A SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILD WAS AFFECTING MY MENTAL
HEALTH. I WAS PLACED ON
DISABILITY FOR A TOTAL OF FOUR
MONTHS. IN THAT FOURTH MONTH I
WAS FIRED. ENDING MY BELOVED
CAREER. THAT CAN GIVE ME HOPE
AND A PURPOSE AFTER MY DIVORCE
MY NEW LIFE HAD DRAMATICALLY
CHANGED WE ARE IN OUR FAMILY A
FIVE ON ONE INCOME. WE
STRUGGLED UNFORTUNATELY THAT
MEANT USING STATE AID LIKE FOOD-STAMPS. HAD MY JOB HAD JUST
GIVEN ME THAT EXTRA SIX WEEKS
OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE I COULD
HAVE HEALED. RETURN TO MY JOB
AND MAINTAIN MY FAMILY AND SAID.
WOMEN ARE THE GIVERS OF LIFE.
WE SHOULD BE GIVEN THAT RESPECT
BELIEVE MOTHERS. NOT TREAT THEM
AS DISPOSABLE WE NEED TIME TO
HEAL OUR BODIES OUR MINDS AND
NURTURE THE LIFE THAT WE
SUSTAIN FROM BEGINNING. GIVE
YOUR MOTHER THE PROPER AMOUNT
OF TIME IS THAT REALLY
NECESSARY IT IS ESSENTIAL TO
THE STRUCTURE OF OUR VERY
SOCIETY. I KNOW OUR GOVERNMENT
GOVERNOR IS FOND OF THE PHRASE
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. THAT SHOULD
INCLUDE MOTHERS. AND I'M
THINKING HERE- GOOD AFTERNOON
NOW- AS I SAID IN MY NAME IS
JENNA GARY AND I'M A SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY AT LEGAL AID AT
WORK- WHERE NONPROFIT LEGAL
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES FOR
THE RIGHTS OF FAMILIES WITH LOW
INCOMES WE WERE AMONG THE
GROUPS THAT HELP PASS PAID
FAMILY LEAVE IN TWO THOUSAND
TWO AND ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION HAVE WORKED TO
IMPROVE THE PROGRAM SENDS IT TO
MAKE IT MORE EQUITABLE. AND
WE'RE FOR DIRECTLY OVER ONE
THOUSAND WORKERS EACH YEAR THAT
CALMED HER WORK AND FAMILY
HELPLINE PEOPLE LIKE SARAH.
THAT ARE STRUGGLING WITH THE
ISSUES SHE JUST DESCRIBED. I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
SHARE SOME OF THOSE STORIES
BECAUSE THESE CALLERS HIGHLIGHT
EXACTLY WHERE THE GAPS ARE AND%
WHAT FAMILIES NEED TO TRULY
MAKE THEM STRIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK BOTH UNDER
JACKSON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ ON YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THESE ISSUES THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS AND CONVENING THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY. SOME TO TALK
ABOUT A LOT OF WHAT THIRTY MEN
DISCUSSED TODAY BECAUSE I THINK.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE AND
THAT'S REALLY WILL LOW INCOME
WORKERS NEED AND SO ONE OF THE
BIGGEST GAPS WE SEE IS JOB
PROTECTION. AS WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM DOES NOT HAVE ANY JOB
PROTECTION ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT
INDIVIDUALS CAN BE FIRED
LEGALLY FOR TAKING BENEFITS
THEY PAY FOR. JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE LAWS CURRENTLY HAVE
STRICT ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
YOU HAD TO BE ON THE JOB ONE
YEAR WORK ONE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY HOURS IN THE YEAR
PRIOR TO YOUR LEAVE. AND FOR
NEW PARENTS YOUR EMPLOYER MUST
HAVE AT LEAST TWENTY EMPLOYEES
AT YOUR WORK SITE WITHIN
SEVENTY FIVE MILES OR- IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO TAKE TIME OFF
YOUR OWN SERIOUS HEALTH
CONDITION OR FOR TO CARE FOR A
FAMILY MEMBER. THEY MUST BE
FIFTY EMPLOYEES AT YOUR WORK
SITE WITHIN SEVENTY FIVE MILES.
THIS MEANS THAT A FULL QUARTER
OF THE WORKFORCE IS EXCLUDED
FROM JOB PROTECTED BONNIE LEAVE
UNDER THE NEW PARENT LEAVE ACT.
AND THAT 40% OF THE WORKFORCE
IS INELIGIBLE FOR JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE TO CARE FOR ILL FAMILY
MEMBER UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY RIGHT THE ACT. BASED ON
EMPLOYER SIZE ALONE. LOW WAGE
WORKERS ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
LESS LIKELY TO QUALIFY FOR JOB
PROTECTION AS THEY ARE MORE
LIKELY. TO WORK FOR SMALL
EMPLOYERS MORE LIKELY TO WORK
PART TIME JOBS USUALLY SEVERAL
PART TIME JOBS. AND MORE LIKELY
TO SWITCH JOBS FREQUENTLY AS A
RESULT MANY LOW WAGE WORKERS
CANNOT USE THE PROGRAM FOR FEAR
OF LOSING THEIR JOB. LOW WAGE
WORKERS MAKE UP 40% OF ELIGIBLE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE RECIPIENTS
BUT ONLY 24% OF ACTUAL
CLAIMANTS SO WHAT DOES THIS
MEAN THIS MEANS THAT LOW WAGE
EARNERS. ARE SUBSIDIZING OF
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM FOR
HIGH WAGE EARNERS. AND I WANT
TO SHARE A COUPLE STORIES OF
OUR HELP L<c.cyan>G COLORS LIKE</c>
SARAH HERE WHO ONE IS JORGE HE
WAS A RECENT COLOR. AND IS THE
FATHER OF THREE HE IS THE SOLE
SUPPORT OF HIS FAMILY WHO
WORKED AS A BUSSER EARNING
SIXTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR FOR A
BAR IN SAN FRANCISCO. WITH
FEWER THAN TWENTY EMPLOYEES
WHEN YASSER TAKE TWO WEEKS OFF
TO CARE FOR HIS NEWBORN HIS
BOSS REPLIED THAT HE COULD NOT
HOLD HIS JOB FOR HIM. JORGE
WOULD HAVE RETURNED AFTER THOSE
TWO WEEKS BUT IS BABY HAD
COMPLICATIONS AND HAD TO RETURN
TO THE HOSPITAL. THE JORGE LOST
HIS JOB HE SAID. MY EMPLOYERS
TO FIRE ME MY FAMILY AND ME
VERY VULNERABLE THIS IS AN
EMOTIONALLY PHYSICALLY AND
FINANCIALLY DRAINING EXPERIENCE
STERN ALREADY STRESSFUL TIME IN
MY LIFE. I AM DEVASTATED THAT I
LOST MY JOB AND EXTRACT THE
HEALTH DEPARTMENT ONLY. FOR HIS
EMPLOYER FEWER THAN TWENTY
EMPLOYEES. NOT COVERED BY THE
NEW PARENT LEAVE AT. THEREFORE
THEY WERE NOT REQUIRED TO
REINSTATE HIM AFTER HIS LEAVE
AND THEY LEGALLY LOSSES JOB. IN
ADDITION TO EMPLOYER SIDE
EXPENSIVE TENURE REQUIREMENTS
LIKE WISELY LOW INCOME WORKERS
WITHOUT JOB PROTECTION ANOTHER
CALLER TASHA LOST HER JOB AT A
LARGE INSURANCE COMPANY WHEN
HER FIVE YEAR OLD DAUGHTER WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH A BRAIN TUMOR.
SHOULD ONLY BEEN ON THE JOB
THREE MONTHS WHEN HER DAUGHTER
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER. AND
THAT SHE WAS NOT YET ELIGIBLE
FOR JOB PROTECTION. AND SHE WAS
IS THAT PAID FAMILY LEAVE IS
NOT COMPREHENSIVE. MOST PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES WHICH WAS BROUGHT UP
BY SIMILAR BRICK CARTY DID NOT
CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE PROGRAM.
AND THEREFORE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
PAID FAMILY LEAVE BENEFITS.
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS ARE
ALSO NOT ELIGIBLE FOR PAID
FAMILY LEAVE- FOR STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE UNLESS
THEY OPT INTO A VERY EXPENSIVE
ALTERNATIVE PROGRAM. AND STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE AND PAID
FAMILY LEAVE EXEMPTS CERTAIN
CATEGORIES OF EMPLOYMENT
INCLUDING EMPLOYEES OF CHURCHES
AND OTHER RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTIONS. WE ALSO IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE A VERY
NARROW DEFINITION OF FAMILY THE
DEFINITION OF FAMILY
CALIFORNIA'S LEAVES LAWS IS
INCONSISTENT AND TOO NARROW.
THANKS A SENATOR JACKSON'S
LEADERSHIP CALIFORNIA EXPAND
THE LIST OF FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
EMPLOYEE CAN CARE FOR UNDER THE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS NOT THE
SAME LIST OF FAMILY MEMBERS
UNDER OUR JOB PROTECTION LAWS.
OUR JOB REDUCTION LOS DEPICTS
LOSES BROADER LESS THIS MEANS
AN EMPLOYEE CAN BE LEGALLY
FIRED FOR TAKING PAID FAMILY
LEAVE. TO CARE FOR SEARS SALE
GRANDPARENT GRANDCHILD SIBLING
PARENT IN LAW OR EVEN ADULT
CHILD. ACROSS THE STATE STATE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY STATES ARE
INCREASINGLY ENACTED LAWS WITH
A BROADER DEFINITION OF FAMILY
FOR EXAMPLE OR IN CONNECTICUT
AND NEW JERSEY DEFINE FAMILY TO
INCLUDE SOMEONE RELATED BY
BLOOD OR AFFINITY. WHO'S CLOSE
ASSOCIATION WITH THE PLAY IS
THE EQUIVALENT OF A FAMILIAL
RELATIONSHIP. CALIFORNIA SHOULD
FOLLOW THEIR LEAD TO REFLECT
THE VALUE OF DIVERSE FAMILIES
PARTICULARLY IN A STATE LIKE
CALIFORNIA. THE NEXT THREE
BARRIER THAT WE FOR TODAY'S
INCLUDE AN ADEQUATE WAGE
REPLACEMENT RATES- THE WAITER
PLACING RATE IS FAR TOO LOW
WE'VE HEARD IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN YOU SIMPLY CANNOT SURVIVE
AND SIXTY OR 70% OF YOUR WAGES.
WHEN YOU'RE BARELY MAKE IT WORK
AND A HUNDRED PERCENT. ALTHOUGH
THE WEIGHT REPLACEMENT RATE WAS
RAISED TO SIXTY OR 70% IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHICH WE'VE
HEARD HERE TODAY. THOSE
RECEIVING 70% IS STILL SAID FAR
TOO WELL AS- KRISTIN POINTED
OUT. THOSE WORKERS WORKING FULL
TIME AT MINIMUM WAGE STILL DID
NOT RECEIVE A 70% WE RECENTLY
SPOKE TO A FATHER TO HIS
YOUNGEST CHILD WAS BORN AT
TWENTY SIX WEEKS JUST TATION
GRAYSON WORKS TWO JOBS AND IS
THE SOLE BRAND WINNER FOR HIS
FAMILY HE COULD NOT AFFORD TO
TAKE PAID FAMILY LEAVE. AT 60%
TODAY'S BABY IS J. CENTER TWO
HOURS OFF FROM WORK TO SPEND
TIME WITH HIS NEWBORN IN THE
NECK YOU. AS A RESULT HE SAID
IT WAS DIFFICULT TO BOND WITH
HIM I WOULD HAVE HAD A STRONGER
BOND MY KIDS IF I THOUGHT I HAD
MORE TIME WITH THEM FROM THE
START. IN A- REASON THE WAITER
PLACE RATE CALIFORNIA SHOULD
ALSO EXTEND THE DURATION OF
PAID FAMILY LEAVE TO ALIGN WITH
THE PERIOD OF JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE. AS WE KNOW CURRENTLY THE
PROGRAM OFFERS SIX WEEKS IT
WILL SOON BE EIGHT WEEKS
STARTING JULY FIRST. BUT JOB
PROTECTION IS AVAILABLE FOR
TWELVE WEEKS. BECAUSE LOW WAGE
WORKERS CANNOT AFFORD TO TAKE
UNPAID TIME OFF THEY'RE LESS
LIKELY TO RECEIVE. AND ARE LESS
LIKELY TO RECEIVE EMPLOYER
PROVIDED PAY. THEY HAVE TO FOR
GO SEVERAL WEEKS THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO TAKE UP. BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T TAKE IT PAID AND
IT'S JUST EXASPERATION IN
EQUITY LEAVE TAKING BETWEEN LOW
AND HIGH EARNERS. FINALLY
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS SUCH AS
DIFFICULTY READING LIVE CLOSER
SUPPORT AT THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT IMPEDE
ACCESS FOR COUNTLESS
CALIFORNIANS. WE RECEIVED MANY
CALLS ON OUR HEALTH PLAN FROM
WORKERS HAS SPENT HOURS OR EVEN
DAYS ATTEMPTING TO CALL THE EDT
TO ASK QUESTIONS OR ADDRESS
CONCERNS ABOUT THEIR PLANS.
ONLY TO BE TOLD THAT THE
MAXIMUM CALL VOLUME HAS BEEN
EXCEEDED TO TRY AGAIN ANOTHER
DAY. MOREOVER HEN APPLICATION
FORMS ARE NOT IN WORKERS ONLY
WHICH IS OTHER THAN ENGLISH. A
NEW LINE ACTED THIS YEAR WILL
REQUIRE EDT TO PUBLISH ALL THE
FORMS IN. LANGUAGES SPOKEN BY
THE STANGEL NUMBER NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING APPLE HANDS. BUT BY
THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
BUT GIVEN THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
LANGUAGE ACCESS NEEDS TO BE
IMPROVED ACROSS THE BOARD WITH
ALL FORMS A CUSTOMER SUPPORT
AVAILABLE IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES. IN ADDITION THE EDT
SHOULD ENSURE THAT ALL THEIR
FORMS ARE RENDON APPROPRIATE
READING LEVELS FOR LOW LITERACY
READERS. THE AGENCY SHOULD ALSO
REMOVE BARRIERS FOR IMMIGRANT
WORKERS MANY OF WHOM WERE
DENIED OR DETERRED FROM
APPLYING DUE TO UNNECESSARY
BURDEN SUCH AS THE CHOIR MEANT
THAT AN ONLINE APPLICATIONS
HAVE A DRIVER'S LICENSE OR
STATE ID. THE EIGHTY SHOULD
ALSO REMOVE BARRIERS FOR
WORKERS OR MIS CLASSIFIED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. BY
PUBLICIZING FACILITATING THE
PROCESS FOR WORKERS TO
CHALLENGE THEM IS
CLASSIFICATION RECEIVE BENEFITS
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO AS A SOME
METRIC. GONZALEZ KNOWS FAR TOO
WELL THIS IS GOING TO BE A BIG
ISSUE IN THE NEXT YEAR. YOU
HEARD ME TELL PATRICK WE GOT
SOMETHING YEAH YEAH. Và TO
REALIZE THE PROMISE OF PEACE
AND LEAVING CALIFORNIA WE NEED
TO MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE TO THOSE
WHO NEED IT MOST. NO ONE SHOULD
BE FIRED FOR TAKING BENEFITS
THEY PAY FOR. WAR TO TAKE TIME
OFF TO CARE FOR NEW CHILD A
REAL FAMILY MEMBER OF. A FAMILY
SHOULD BE UNIVERSAL AND WE'D
REPLACEMENT SHOULD BE HIGHER
ESPECIALLY FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS
AND THE DURATION SHOULD BE
EXTENDED TO MATCH THE PERIOD OF
JOB PROTECTION. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO GO JUST A LITTLE
BIT QUICKER AND HAVE NO TIME
FOR KILLING ME. QUICK NOTE JUST
CHECKING. I WILL DO MY BEST.
THANK YOU CHAIR IS GONZALEZ AND
JACKSON AND SLIMMER A MCCARTY
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
HERE TODAY I SWEAR I'M NOT
TEXTING JUST TIMING MYSELF. SO
YES THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT'S
VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO OUR
HEARTS AT THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE WERE. ONE OF THE
FEW GROUPS THAT CO SPONSORED
THE LEGISLATION IN TWO THOUSAND
TWO THAT CREATED THE PROGRAM AT
THIS POINT. THE BENEFITS ARE SO
CLEAR AND OBVIOUS THAT IT'S
REALLY REALLY HARD TO IMAGINE A
WORLDWITHOUT THIS PROGRAM THAT
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN THERE
REALLY WAS NOTHING OTHER THAN
WHAT. YOU UNION WAS ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE WHAT YOUR EMPLOYER
WAS WILLING TO OFFER AND IT WAS
ALL OVER THE PLACE AND TOUGH TO
ENFORCE AND WHERE WE ARE NOW IS
IN A MUCH MUCH BETTER PLACE.
IT'S KIND OF AN INSPIRING
EXAMPLE OF SUCCESSFUL PUBLIC
POLICY REALLY CHANGING THE
CULTURE. THAT PARENTS
ESPECIALLY MALE PARENTS REALLY
LOOK AT THEIR JOB. OF BEING A
PARENT AS DIFFERENTLY NOW THAN
THEY DID PRIOR TO THE EXISTENCE
OF THE PROGRAM THAT. WITH THIS
ALLOWANCE OF THEIR IN THE LAW.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT REALLY IT
DOES SEND A MESSAGE TO THOSE
WORKERS THAT. THIS IS A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY THIS IS
SOMETHING THE GOVERNMENT IS
INVOLVED IN THIS IS SOMETHING
YOU'RE INVOLVED AND WE ALL NEED
TO DO THIS WE ALL NEED TO. TAKE
THIS TIME TO BOND WITH OUR
CHILDREN. AND AS A RESULT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE VERY MUCH
WANT TO PROTECT. WE VERY MUCH
DO WANT TO EXPAND AND WE AGREE
THAT THE CURRENT BENEFIT
DURATION WAGER PLACEMENT ARE
OFTEN NOT ENOUGH AND THEY
SHOULD BE EXPANDED- OVERALL WE
HOPE THAT THIS RENEWED FOCUS ON
THE PROGRAM. DOES THOSE START A
LONG OVERDUE CONVERSATION ABOUT
FINANCING THE PROGRAM. AND
PARTICULARLY WHETHER OR NOT THE
WAY THAT WE FINANCE THE PROGRAM
GIVES US A- WIDE ENOUGH BASIS
ON WHICH TO BUILD. THE IDEAL
PROGRAMS THAT WERE ALL
CONSIDERING HERE TODAY. AS WAS
MENTIONED THE FAMILY PROGRAM IS
CURRENTLY FUNDED ENTIRELY
THROUGH THE D. I. FUND. THAT
WAS BEGIN I THINK IN NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN. AND WAS CREATED TO
GIVE WORKERS. KIND OF STORE
MONEY FOR WHEN THEY SUFFER A
NON. FULL NON WORK RELATED
INJURY FOR UP TO A YEAR. AND
ARE WE CREATE THE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE PROGRAM. IT INCLUDED BOTH
SIX WEEKS IT WAS JUST KIND OF
PUT INTO THE D. I'VE FOUGHT.
WITH SIX WEEKS PAID FOR BY THE
WORKER AND SIX WEEKS PAID FOR
BY THE EMPLOYER- EARLY IN THE
SESSION THE SIX WEEKS. WERE TO
BE FUNDED BY THE EMPLOYER WERE
TAKEN OUT. AND SO WHAT WE WERE
LEFT WITH WAS ESSENTIALLY HALF
OF THE PROGRAM THAT WAS
ENVISIONED. AND THAT'S- WHERE
THINGS STOOD FOR QUITE AWHILE.
AS A RESULT THE MISSION BY THE
FIRST PANEL. REALLY AREN'T
SOMETHING OF AN OUTLIER WITH
RESPECT TO OTHERS. EIGHT OF THE
NINE THAT OFFICE PROGRAM. OTHER
WEAPONS OUT WORKERS TO FUND THE
ENTIRE PROGRAM. AND I BELIEVE
THAT'S US RHODE ISLAND CONNECT
FOR THE ONLY ONES. IS OUT OF
THE OTHER STATES EITHER SPLIT
THE RESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN.
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES OR THEY
ASK EMPLOYERS TO FUND THE
ENTIRE PROGRAM. OTHER COUNTRIES
ALSO DO SOMETHING SIMILAR WHERE
THE VAST MAJORITYASK EMPLOYERS
THE FUN PART OF THE PROGRAM.
THE MOST COMMON WAY IS ACTUALLY
THROUGH THE SOCIAL SECURITY
PROGRAM OF THAT COUNTRY. AND SO
AS FAR AS I CAN TELL IT'S
USUALLY KIND OF LIKE IT IS HERE
WHERE IT'S HOW FROM THE BY THE
WORKER HOW FUNDED BY THE
EMPLOYER. AND ARE ALSO
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES- BOTH
PARTIES. HAVE PUT FORTH PAID
FAMILY PROGRAMS THAT WERE
FUNDED BY BOTH. SUPPORT PLANS
THAT EITHER SHARE THE
RESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN BOTH
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS OR PUT
ALL OF THE RESPONSIBILITY ON
EMPLOYERS. AND ARE NONE OTHER
THAN DONALD TRUMP PROPOSE ONE
THAT IS FUNDED ALL BY
EMPLOYERS- THERE WERE SOME
OTHER ISSUES WITH THE ONES
PROPOSED BY THAT PARTY BUT WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO MENTION
THAT. IT DOES SEEM LIKE THE
NATIONAL PERSPECTIVE HERE IS OF
ONE THAT SHOULD AT A MINIMUM BE
A SHARED RESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS- AND SO
WE THINK THAT THAT IS THERE FOR
A REASON THAT AS WAS ALSO
MENTIONED THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT VERY MUCH BENEFITS BOTH
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS THAT.
THERE ARE CLEAR QUANTIFIABLE
SAVINGS IN TERMS OF REDUCING
THE COST OF EMPLOYER PROVIDED
BENEFITS THAT. PRIOR TO PAID
FAMILY LEAVE EMPLOYERS IF THEY
DID OFFER THE PAY FOR THE WHOLE
THING. AND WE CREATED THE
PROGRAM THEY ONLY HAD TO PAY
4405% OF IT THE FIRST THIS WEEK
AND- AS WE EXPANDED. ACOSTA
LAWYER DOWN THE COST TO THE
WORKER GOES UP AS LONG AS WE
KEEP THE EXIST FINANCING
STRUCTURE. THEY'RE ALSO SAVINGS
INVOLVED IN NOT HAVING TO
RECRUIT AND TRAIN NEW WORKERS.
BECAUSE THIS ALLOWS WORKERS TO
GO BACK TO THE JOB HEY DON'T
HAVE TO QUIT AND GO FIND A NEW
ONE. AND THEY'RE ALSO
PRODUCTIVITY. S. ON MOTHER
REALLY TWO PIECES TO THAT ONE
WAS WHAT WILL LIKELY AT SOME
POINT B. A TAX INCREASE FOR
WORKERS. AND THEN ALSO A
REDUCTION IN THE SOLVENCY
REQUIREMENTS- WE THINK WERE
ARGUABLY UNFAIR FOR A FEW
REASONS. THE FIRST OF WHICH IS
THERE'S A RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN.
THE STI FUND AND THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM THAT WE
DON'T THINK IT'S ENOUGH
ATTENTION AND THAT'S THAT. WHEN
A WORKER SUFFERS AN ON THE JOB
INJURY THE EMPLOYER FIGHTS THE
CLAIM THEY SAY WE DON'T THINK
THAT HAPPENED HERE AT WORK. THE
WORKER USUALLY HAS TO GO OUT ON
DISABILITY INSURANCE THEY TELL
ET DE THAT THIS IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING. AND THEN AT THE END
OF THE APPEALS BOARD FINDS THAT
IT WAS A COMPENSABLE INJURY.
EDS SUPPOSED TO GO BACK TO THE
EMPLOYER GET THEIR MONEY BACK.
WE'RE TOLD THAT PRETTY RARELY
HAPPENS AND THAT WHEN IT DOES
HAPPEN IT'S SETTLED FOR MUCH
LOWER AMOUNT SO. THERE'S A
WHOLE LOT OF MONEY THAT SHE IN
THE I FROM THAT'S NOT THERE.
THE BEST ESTIMATE THAT WE'VE
GOT IS THAT THERE'S ABOUT ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS THAT
SHOULD BE ON THE FIVE THAT'S
NOT BECAUSE OF THIS ISSUE-
THERE ARE ALSO A CERTAIN THAT
THE FUNDAMENTAL INSOLVENCY THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SYSTEM
IS CONNECTED TO THIS. THAT TIME
THE WIFE WHEN INSOLVENT LAST
RECESSION. THEY BORROWED
THROUGH THE TEN DOLLARS IT WAS
CLOSE TO DOLLARS. OUT OF THE D.
I. FUNDED COVER THE INTEREST ON
THOSE. WAS VERY PREDICTABLE
WIND THAT THAT MIGHT HAPPEN
EVERY AND THAT THERE'S A
RECESSION WE DON'T. ADEQUATELY
FUND THE U. I. SYSTEM. WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE A VERY GOOD PLAN
FOR WHAT TO DO TO COVER THAT
INTEREST AND SO THE ONLY OPTION
WE ARE LEFT WITH LAST TIME WAS
TO. BASICALLY ASK WORKERS TO
BAIL OUT EMPLOYERS BECAUSE WE
JUST COLLECTIVELY. SEEM TO NOT
BE WILLING TO ADEQUATELY FUND
THE U. I. SYSTEM. AND SO THAT'S-AN ISSUE THERE'S ALSO THE
CONCERN THAT. AS THE FIRST
PANEL MENTIONED THAT WORKER
WHICH IS REALLY HAVEN'T GOT.
MUCH IF AT ALL IN THE LAST
FORTY YEARS AND- IF WE DO THINK
THAT THIS PROGRAM IS WORTH
EXPANDING. WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE WORKERS
ARE REALLY IN A PLACE TO
ABSORB. HIGHER TAXES HIGHER
IMPACTS ON. THE PHONE WHAT WE
LIKE TO DO AND ALSO JUST
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON THE ADEQUACY
RATE. SO WE PAID FOR WILL WE
TRY TO PAY FOR MOST OF WHAT WE
DID THIS YEAR BY REDUCING THAT
ADEQUACY RATE FROM ONE POINT
FOUR FIVE TO ONE POINT SPREE.
MEETING THAT WE SET THE WORKER
TAX RATE AT. WHAT DO WE PAY OUT
WE MULTIPLY THAT BY THAT ACT
WAS HERE. AND THAT'S WHERE WE
SET THE RIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S WHAT CAME IN. AND AT ONE
POINT FOUR FIVE EQUITY FACTOR.
WAS JUST PULL THE SCOTT WE CAN
HAVE A PRETTY PAINFUL PROCESS
OF TRIAL AND ERROR IN THE PAST
WHERE. THERE WERE THREE YEARS
THE FUND WENT SOFT AND SO TO
AVOID THAT WHAT WE HAD TO DO
WAS. BASICALLY RIGHT TO WEAR IT
NOW NOT WHERE IT'S BEEN IT'S-
BEEN. HE HASN'T BEEN A PROBLEM.
BUT WE'RE PRETTY CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS ONE POINT 3%
ADEQUACY RATE- MY ARM. THERE
ARE TWENTY SIX YEARS SINCE
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. THAT THE
ADVISORY HAS DIPPED BELOW THAT.
SO WERE THAT TO HAPPEN NOW.
THERE REALLY KNOW WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN WE WOULD PROBABLY REDUCE
BENEFITS WHICH IS WHAT WE DID
LAST TIME. AND THAT'S MORE THAN
A THIRD OF THE TIME IT'S GONE
BELOW THAT AND SO. HOPEFULLY
HISTORY WILL BE A GUIDE HERE
BUT WE WON'T REALLY KNOW WAS
HAVE TO SEE HOW IT HAPPENS- AND
IN THE LAST WEEK WE WANTED TO.
IT WAS JUST THAT. AS FAR AS
EXPANDING PAID FAMILY BENEFITS
AGAIN SOMETHING THAT WE VERY
MUCH SUPPORT BOTH IN TERMS OF
DURATION WAGER PLACEMENT BUT-
THE FACT OF. ITS OWN. IN A
WOVEN INTO THE ES DE I SYSTEM
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT ONE AND
THAT WERE WE TO SAY. RAISE THE
WAITER PLACEMENT RATE FOR PAID
FAMILY WITHOUT DOING THE SAME
DISABILITY INSURANCE. LIKE IT
OR NOT WE'RE SENDING A MESSAGE
TO WORKERS THAT THE STATE.
PRIORITIZE AS ONE OVER THE
OTHER AND SO. NOT ALL OF OUR
AFFILIATES NOT ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS WOULD AGREE WITH THAT
THAT. THERE ARE SOME WHO THINK
THAT. YOU KNOW TAKING TIME OFF
TO CARE FOR THEIR OWN SERIOUS
HEALTH CONCERN IS EVERY BIT AS
IMPORTANT AS BABY BONDING OR-
TAKING TIME OFF TO CARE FOR A
SICK RELATIVE A SICK PARENT
SICK CHILD. IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS BABY BONDING BUT
THAT. IF WE DO. I'M OUT AND SAY
THAT ONE SHOULD BE REIMBURSED
AT A HIGHER RATE THAN THE
OTHER. IT'S LIKELY GOING TO
CREATE A LOT OF FILL A LOT OF
CONCERN AMONG OUR MEMBERS THAT.
MAY NOT BE THE INTENT BUT WOULD
LIKELY BE THE OUTCOME AND SO.
THOSE ARE JUST SOME ISSUES AND-
WE DO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
DOCTOR WRITTEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- JUST GONNA HOPEFULLY
SLIDE UP HERE. THE MEDIA. GREAT
OKAY SO THANK YOU IM AND THANK
YOU BOTH FOR OF NOT ALLOWING ME
TO BE HERE TODAY I'M GONNA BE
TALKING ABOUT IN A VISIBLE
POPULATION WITH IN OUR WORK
POPULATION- WHICH ARE FAMILY
CARE GIVERS. OVER THE YEARS WE
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA IF
THEY'RE ACTUALLY FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION FAMILY CARE GIVERS.
CURRENTLY A MAJORITY OF THEM
WORK OVER 50% AND MOST
IDENTIFIES FEMALE. CURRENTLY
THERE ARE ABOUT SEVEN POTENTIAL
CARE GIVERS FOR EVERY PERSON
OVER THE AGE OF EIGHTY AND
CURRENTLY CARE GIVERS PROVIDE
MORE INTENSIVE AND COMPLEX CARE
THEN AT ANY OTHER TIME IN
HISTORY AS MEDICAL NURSING
TASKS AND MULTIPLE HEALTH
CONDITIONS HAVE INCREASED. OVER
TIME. THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
CURRENTLY BUT WHAT IS NOW
DOESN'T REFLECT THE FUTURE. A
MERE TEN YEARS THE CARE GIVER
SUPPORT RATIO IS EXPECTED TO
PLUMMET AS BOOMERS TRANSITION
FROM YOUNG CARE GIVERS INTO
PEOPLE WHO NEED CARE. BY TWENTY
THIRTY THE SUPPORT RATIO WILL
BE ABOUT FOUR CARE GIVERS TO
EVERY PERSON OVER THE AGE OF
EIGHTY YEARS OLD AND BY TWENTY
FIFTY IT IS GOING TO BE BELOW
THREE TO ONE. RIGHT NOW THE
CHALLENGES OF CARE GIVERS FACE
WILL REALLY BE RISING AS THE
POPULATION OF PERSONS WITH
DEMENTIA CHRONIC PAIN MULTIPLE
MEDICAL PROBLEMS CONTINUE TO
SWELL IN OUR STATE. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND A SURVEY FUNDED BY
A. R. P. OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS
THEY FOUND IT A FULL 41% OF
THOSE SURVEYED ARE OR HAVE BEEN
UNPAID FAMILY CARE GIVERS.
CURRENTLY 74% OF THOSE CARE
GIVERS REPORT FEELING STRESSED
BY WORKING AND PROVIDING CARE
AT THE SAME TIME. ANOTHER 71%
REPORTED HAVING TO CHANGE THEIR
WORK SCHEDULE TO ACCOMMODATE
CAREGIVING RESPONSIBILITIES.
BUT AGAIN WHAT CURRENT DOESN'T
REFLECT THE FUTURE. IN TWENTY
YEARS IT IS PROJECTED THAT 51%
OF WORKERS WILL BE- EXPERIENCE
HAVING SOME EXPERIENCE WITH
FAMILY CARE GIVING SO WE'RE
GOING FROM A 44% OF WORKERS
251% AND A MAJORITY OF THEM
WILL STILL BE IN THE WORK
FORCE. AS OLDER CARE GIVERS.
LOOKING AT DEMOGRAPHICS
CURRENTLY THE MAJORITY OF CARE
GIVERS ARE WHITE BUT BY TWENTY
FIFTY THIS PROFILE WILL CHANGE
AND THE PROPORTION OF RACIAL
AND ETHNIC CARE GIVERS WILL BE
CLOSER TO THE MAJORITY. AND
ALSO A MAJORITY OF THOSE CARE
GIVERS WILL BE OVER THE AGE OF
SEVENTY YEARS OLD THEMSELVES.
THIS MONTH. I ACTUALLY DID IF
YOU LOOK AT THE LITTLE HEART
THERE I DID A QUICK REVIEW OF
NEWSPAPER ARTICLES IN THE PAST
YEAR WHICH FEATURED CARE GIVING.
THE DOODLE REPRESENTS KEY WORDS
THAT WERE USED IN THE ARTICLE
HEADLIGHTS THE MORE OFTEN THE
WORD IS USED THE LARGER THE
FOUGHT. NOW IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ARTICLES CURRENTLY THERE'S A
RISING TIDE OF AWARENESS AMONG
OUR BLOOMERS AND ARE
MILLENNIALS. AND ARE THEY ARE
REALLY BMP IMPACTED BY CARE
GIVING BUT THEY'R ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT WORK AND STRESS
AT THE SAME TIME. ANOTHER
REVIEW OF EMPIRICAL STUDIES
ALSO SUGGEST THE CARE GIVERS
REPORT POOR MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH THE NON CARE GIVERS.
THEY ALSO RECEIVE THE CARE
RECEIVER HOWEVER WHO DOES HAVE
A CARE GIVER SHOW BETTER HEALTH
pOUTCOMES AND LOWER RATES OF
HOSPITAL USAGE AND ARE LESS
LIKELY TO USE INSTITUTIONAL
CARE. SO WHAT IS CURRENTLY
HAPPENING TO CALIFORNIA'S
CARING FAMILIES WELL RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE CAUGHT IN A RIP TIDE
AND REALLY YELLING FOR HELP AND
THE ONLY LIFE GUARD IS NOT
PAYING ANY ATTENTION TO THE
FAMILY CARE GIVER. THE CLAIMS
PROCESS FOR THE PFL
INTERMITTENT LEAVE IS SO
TREACHEROUS THAT MOST CARE
GIVERS WON'T EVEN ATTEMPT TO
FILL OUT THE FORMS. THIS MIGHT
EXPLAIN WHY ONLY 10% OF PFL
CLAIMS ARE FOR CARE GIVERS BUT
WE KNOW THAT THEY SPEND
DEMOGRAPHICS THAT'S FAR TOO LOW.
CARE GIVERS AND NEED TO TAKE
TIME OFF TO HELP A SICK PARROT
OR GRAVELY ILL LEFT ONE ARE
JUST GIVING UP THEIR CUTTING
BACK ON HOURS AND THEY'RE
LEAVING THE WORK FORCE ARE
WORKING MORE AND FEELING MORE
STRESS MOREOVER WOMEN AND
ETHNIC AND RACIAL POPULATIONS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO FALL INTO
THIS PATTERN. WOMEN AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR ARE JEOPARDIZING THEIR
HEALTH AND FINANCIAL FUTURES SO
THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE OVER
FIFTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS TO
CALIFORNIA. IN UNPAID LONG TERM
CARE BUT CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
HAVE AN ADEQUATE SAFETY NET TO
CATCH THEM BEFORE THEY DROUGHT.
AND WHY SHOULD WE CARE WHAT
HAPPENS TO THESE CARE GIVERS.
LET'S BE REAL I MEAN ISN'T CARE
GIVING A PRIVATE FAMILY ISSUE.
IS WHAT WE DO FOR LOVE. YOU
KNOW LET THE FAMILIES BE THE
LIFE PRESERVERS I MEAN HASN'T
ALWAYS BEEN THAT WAY. WELL THE
FAMILY STRUCTURE REALLY HAS
CHANGED AND SO HAS THE NATURE
OF CARE GIVING. THERE NOW AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE FEWER
PEOPLE TO TAKE CARE OF THE
GROWING OLDER POPULATION. MORE
PEOPLE ARE REQUIRING CHRONIC
CARE AND CARE NEEDS THAT
REQUIRE SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE
THAT IN THE PAST WE'RE REALLY
DONE BY NURSES. AND OTHER
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND
THEY'RE BEING DONE IN THE HOME
UNSUPERVISED. MORE OF THE
TRADITIONAL CARE GIVERS WHO
WERE WOMEN ARE ALSO WORKING.
THEIR SINGLE HAVE ADULT
CHILDREN AND THEY REALLY CAUGHT
IN WHAT WEEK OFTEN HERE AS THE
SANDWICH GENERATION. AND
THEY'RE ALSO NEED THE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. OVERALL THE
DEMOGRAPHICS AND FAMILY
STRUCTURE CHANGES IN CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUGGEST THAT IF WE
DON'T SUPPORT CARE GIVERS TO
HELP MAINTAIN FAMILY MEMBERS IN
THEIR HOME. OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM WILL BE RAPIDLY
OVERWHELMED WITH THE RISING
COST OF INSTITUTIONAL CARE. SO
WHAT DO I RECOMMEND WE CAN
START RESCUING THESE CARE
GIVERS AND OUR STATE'S ECONOMY
TODAY IF WE LOOK AT THE SIX
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
PRESENTED IN A RECENT SURVEY.
BY BOTH HUMAN IMPACT PARTNERS
AND A. R. P. WE NEED TO PROVIDE
JOB PROTECTION SO THAT THESE
CARE GIVERS WHO TEND TO BE
OLDER ARE NOT FORCED OUT OF THE
WORKPLACE WITH LITTLE
OPPORTUNITY OF BEING RE HIRED
BECAUSE OF THEIR AGE WE NEED TO
PROVIDE TAX CREDITS SO THAT OUT
OF POCKET SPENDING IS REDUCED.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT WAYS TO
OFFSET LOST RETIREMENT INCOME
SO THAT THEY DON'T END UP
HOMELESS ARE IN POVERTY. WE
NEED TO IMPROVE HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH ASSESSMENTS TO
IDENTIFY WORKING CARE GIVERS SO
WE CAN PROVIDE SUPPORT EARLY.
AND NOT WHEN THEY BECOME TOO
DEPRESSED OR SICK TO CONTINUE
WORKING. WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
WOMEN WHO ARE MORE LIKELY TO
NEED BOTH PARENTAL AND FAMILY
pTHEIR LIFETIME. ARE NOT
PENALIZED BY PAID FAMILY LEAVE
POLICIES NOW OR IN THE FUTURE.
AND FINALLY WE NEED TO ASSIST
PEOPLE OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS AND
THOSE WORKING IN LOW WAGE JOBS
WHO ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY PFL POLICIES THEY
DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE WAGE
REPLACEMENT- LACK OF JOB
PROTECTIONS. IF WE BEGIN NOW.
WE CAN REALLY TURN THE TIDE SO
THAT IN TWENTY YEARS CALIFORNIA
WILL NOT DROWN IN RISING HEALTH
CARE COSTS. RISING NO JUST
NURSING HOME UTILIZATION AND IN
A FLOOD OF STRESSED OUT AND
FINANCIALLY UNSTABLE FAMILY
CAREGIVERS WHO ARE NO LONGER
ABLE TO TREAD WATER. THANK YOU.
SO I AM CONNECT TALK BRIEFLY
JUST ABOUT THE- KIND OF THE
POSITIVE EXCITING TIME WERE AND
EVEN THOUGH I REALLY LIVE IN
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT WE JUST
HEARD. IN TERMS OF THE WORK
THAT THAT I'M CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY COALITION IS FOCUSED
ON- FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS
ESPECIALLY REALLY TRYING TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO PAID LEAVE-
BUT STILL I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
WORK FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AND IN A
LOT OF WAYS. I'VE NEVER HAD SO
MUCH HOPE AND EXCITEMENT ABOUT
I WHERE I THINK WE CAN GO NEXT.
NOT JUST IN THE STATE WITH A
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH A LOT
OF OUR LEGISLATORS THAT HAVE
BEEN GREAT CHAMPIONS ON THIS
WORK AT THE LEGISLATORS HERE
AND THIS- PANEL BUT- ALSO JUST
THE GROWING MOMENTUM AND
MOVEMENT AROUND THE COUNTRY-
REALLY FOR MEANINGFUL CHANGE
AMPLE OF THE REASONS I
EMPHASIZE THAT MOVEMENT
BUILDING. IS FEEL LIKE THAT'S
ULTIMATELY THE WAY WERE VûI
SOME OF THEM GET IF THINGS LIKE
WITH ME THE ARMY BONTA TRUMP
PEOPLE LIKE. SUCH AS- THE ONLY
WAY WE CAN REALLY MOVE RIGHT-
POLICY THAT MEANING FOR THE-
PEOPLE IS I BUILDING THEM MAN
OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTIVE
AND HAVE THEIR VOICES AT THE
TABLE. THAT'S REALLY THE ROLE
OF THE COLD SENATE. WORK THAT
THESE GROUPS HERE THE ENGAGED.
IN DOING IS FOR THESE. PEOPLE
TO FALL. YOU KNOW I. THAT. IN
THAT DIRECTION RIGHT NOW IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO WE HELPED PASSED
THE FIRST LEAVE LAW IN THE
COUNTRY WITHOUT IT WOULD TAKE
TEN YEARS. IT HAPPENED IN ONE
YEAR THAT TEN YEARS HAS BEEN
MORE AND KIND OF TRYING TO
IMPROVE IT. MAKE IT REALLY WORK
FOR MORE PEOPLE BUT WHEN IT
HAPPENED SO QUICKLY ONE OF THE
POSITIVES IS THAT IT REALLY.
SPARKED THE IMAGINATION OF
PEOPLE ALL OVER THE COUNTRY I
MEAN I GOT HEADLINES ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY. EVEN ON WEST WING
A YEAR BEFORE THEY WERE SAYING
AHA AND THEN WE'LL HAVE PAID
LEAVE LIKE THAT. WOULD NEVER
HAPPEN YOU KNOW IN THE UNITED
STATES AND AS WE KNOWN AS IS
CENTER JACKSON MENTIONED WERE
QUITE ALONE. IN THE UNITED
STATES AND BEING ONE OF THE FEW
COUNTRIES- MORE THAN FIFTY
COUNTRIES HAVE SIX MONTHS OF
PAID LEAVE. FOR AT LEAST ONE
PARENT SO WE'RE WE'RE WAY
BEHIND THERE BUT SINCE WE
SPARKS THIS A LOT OF STATES IN
EIGHT STATES HAVE LEAVE LAWS.
WE ARE PART OF A NETWORK OF
TWENTY SEVEN STATE COALITIONS.
EVEN IN STATES YOU WOULDN'T
IMAGINE THAT ARE FIGHTING FOR
PAID SICK DAYS AND PAID LEAVE.
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT GIVE US
THE RIGHT TO CARE FOR OURSELVES
AND CARE. HEATHER AND HAVE
ECONOMIC SECURITY WHILE DOING
SO WHICH- REALLY SHOULD BE
UNIVERSAL AND PART OF WHY I
THINK WE NEED TO PUSH TOWARD
THAT UNIVERSAL. GOAL IS THAT
THAT GETS RID OF THE OTHER
PROBLEM OF PEOPLE NOT KNOWING
WHETHER THEY HAVE THE RIGHT. A
LOT OF COUNTRIES PEOPLE AREN'T
SITTING HERE WONDERING IF THEY
QUALIFY FOR THIS OR THAT OR IF
THEY CAN TAKE TIME OFF ON THAT
BABY. ARE THEIR PARENT NEEDS
THEM THEY JUST DON'T HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT IT BECAUSE IT IS
YOUR PERSONAL. THEY SHOULD BE
AND THAT'S- REALLY WHERE I
THINK. WE NEED TO BE HAD IT BUT
I THINK WE'RE IN. A BETTER
POSITION THAN WE'VE EVER BEEN
BEFORE IN THIS STATE BECAUSE
THE MINUTE WE PASSED PAID LEAVE
GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS WAS OUT AS
YOU ALL REMEMBER. AND SOMEBODY
WHO DON'T LIKE THE PROGRAM SOME
BUT IT'S WAS IN. AND IT WAS A
FIGHT EVEN TO NOT HAVE
DECIMATED PROGRAM DIFFERENT
WAYS. SO THAT'S BEEN A LOT OF
OUR WORK HAS BEEN PROTECTING
INTERACTIVE. AND THAT. I'M
STILL ONE OF THE THINGS. I
THINK. IS REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT KIND OF THE
MOVEMENT. THIS HOW MEANINGFUL
THE PROBE. IS OR JUST THE RIGHT
TO CARRY IS THE PEOPLE- IF
YOU'VE BEEN TO A COALITION. YOU
KNOW THAT WE ALWAYS KIND OF
GROUND OURSELVES IN. WHY THIS
MATTERS TO US INTO OUR
ORGANIZATIONS. AND THE
COMMUNITIES WE REPRESENT AND
WHETHER IT'S PEOPLE. FIGHTING
FOR A LOW WAGE WORKERS WHETHER
IT'S- NEW IMMIGRANT
ORGANIZER'S. OF PEOPLE ALL TALK
ABOUT WHY THIS SHOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT REALLY WORKS
FOR. YOU KNOW THEM IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND- YOU KNOW I
TOOK IT I NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD- HOW AND UP WITH I HAVE
THREE KIDS TO AND THAT'S THAT'S
HARD. THAT IS TO HAVE ONE'S I
USED TO THINK- WHEN WE PASSED A
LEVY A BUT I'LL TAKE IT FROM MY
PARENTS AND DAY. AND I HAD
TWINS THAT IT WAS A HIGH RISK
PREGNANCY. AND I WAS OUT ON
PREGNANCY DISABILITY LEAVE AND
I NEEDED PAID LEAVE- BEEN IT
JUST WAS SO MEANINGFUL FOR ME.
TO BE ABLETO HAVE THAT TIME-
BUT A COUPLE WEEKS AGO I WAS
THAT- IN MY SPARE TIME I WORK
ON. HOUSING RIGHTS AND RENTERS
RIGHTS AND I WAS AT A BIGGEST.
BILLY AND IT INGLEWOOD. TONS OF
RENTERS ALL OVER THE STATE
WHERE THERE AND IT WAS A LONG
LINE FOR LANCE. I'M OVERLY
FRIENDLY AND REALLY NOSY. THE
WOMAN BEHIND ME I SO TALKING TO
HER. AND SHE HAS WORKED AT A
JOB FOR FOURTEEN YEARS. TOOK
TIME OFF BECAUSE HER DAUGHTER
HAD. A SERIOUS HEALTH CONDITION
WAS IN THE HOSPITAL AND THEY
FIRED HER. AND IT'S THE GUY
KNOWS ENOUGH TO KNOW IT
DEFINITELY A LARGE ENOUGH
EMPLOYER. GIVING YOU HER.
CONTACT INFO. SHE SAID I COULD.
SO THIS IS JUST IT'S NOT
WORKING FOR EVERYBODY EQUALLY
WHEN I TAKE IT. I NOT ONLY. MY
BOSS WAS THE WOMAN WHO TRAPPED
TOM RANKIN IN THE CAR AND MADE
HIM. BECOME THE COAST. THIS IS
A VERY BEHIND THAT'S THE
PHARMACY WAS VERY BEHIND PAID
LEAVE. SO I HAD A UNION
CONTRACTS SO EVEN IF MY BOSS
CHANGED HER MIND. I HAD A LOT
OF THINGS GOING FOR ME WHEN I
TOOK IT FOR THE TWINS. WE NEED
EVERYBODY TO HAVE THAT SAME YOU
KNOW THING AND THAT'S WHY WE-
EVEN THOUGH WE PASSED THE LEAVE
EVEN THOUGH WE'VE EXPANDED THAT
THAT'S WHY I THINK. SO MANY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE COMING
TOGETHER IN DECEMBER. TO PLAN
OUR WORK FOR THE NEXT YEAR. AND
IT REALLY JUST COUNTY TOP DOWN
BUT WE WANT TO REALLY PUSH.
THINGS IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
THAT THEY NEED TO GO. OVER A- I
AM SAYING IS THAT. YOU KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE TALK TO WHAT'S-
IN THE DIFFERENT STATES AND YOU
KNOW WHERE WE'RE GOING. WE NEED
TO LOOK AT. LIKE NEW YORK WHICH
IN THEIR VERY FIRST SEE HER.
HAVE HER FATHER'S TAKE A MORE
CARE GIVERS TICKET. I'M A
MAJORITY PEOPLE MAKING FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TAKING IT. I
THAT REIGNS AT VERY DIFFERENT
THAN CALIFORNIA I THINK JOHN
UNIVERSAL JOBMATCH. IS A VERY
BIG REASON FOR THAT BECAUSE- AS
MOST OF YOU KNOW NEW YORK HAS
EVEN LESS. PROFESSOR RIGHT NOW.
THOUGH THEY'LL BE RAMPS. TO
INTO. WHETHER IT'S THE SEVEN.
YOU. KNOW HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
NEED TO BE. A LOT MORE.
ULTIMATELY I THINK AS WE HAVE
THIS MOMENTUM FROM. THE
ADMINISTRATION OUR LEGISLATIVE.
WE IN THE COALITION ARE GOING
INTO A YEAR WHERE WE REALLY
WANT TO BE IN THE FIELD.
BUILDING UP THAT'S OF. RECENTLY
HAD AN IN PERSON MEETING. WITH
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT WITH PATRICK AND ALL
HIS STAFF. IN LA WE HAD PEOPLE
THAT A FATHER FROM SAN DIEGO
JERRY SOUND OF ALL THE CAME.
AND SPOKE ABOUT WHERE TO PLACE
AND- WE'RE REALLY DOING THAT
WORK OF BRINGING PEOPLE TO THE
TABLE. WHO CAN HELP CRAFT WHAT
WE HAVE IN THE NEXT DAY. VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE REALLY HEAR
THOSE VOICES. JUST YESTERDAY MY
DAUGHTER HAD THIS DENTAL
SURGERY ONE OF THE TWINS AND IT
WAS REALLY INTENSE BECAUSE
ACTUALLY HAD TO HAVE SOME-
SEDATION SO IT WAS A MUCH
BIGGER DEAL AND IT WAS A LITTLE
BIT PAINFUL AND AT THE END OF
THE DAY SHE BECAUSE- THIS IS A
REALLY GREAT DAY I HAVE BOTH MY
MOM. WITH ME THIS MORNING.
FLICK. BECAUSE I'M DIVORCED BUT
I'M FOR BETTER FOR WORSE MY
EXCELLENCE EIGHT. FOR ME LATELY
SEE THE MOTHER. BUT JUST THE
IDEA THAT WE ARE BOTH OF THEIR
IN THE SAME PLACE. AND WE WERE
ABLE TO BE WITH HER AT THAT
TIME THAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO HER AND I WAS LIKE OH MY GOD.
ANYWAY I JUST FOR MY PART IS TO
SET. BRINGING PEOPLE TABLE
DOING ALL THE WORK THAT
EVERYBODY HERE IS DOING IS
GOING TO BE KEY. THANK YOU FOR
SERRANO I THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK THAT YOU HAVE
DONE ON THIS- WE HAVE A HARD
STOP AT ONE AT LEAST I.
DEFINITELY DO SO- INCORPORATED
IN OUR QUESTIONS WE WANT TO
OPEN UP MAKE SURE IF THERE IS-
QUESTIONS FROM THE PUBLIC. WHAT
A WOULD BE BEFORE YOU LEAVE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE PUBLIC SO THAT WE- IF
WE- HAVE. PROBABLY ALL HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR THE GROUP UP
FRONT BUT- IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM. THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO COME ON DOWN. I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT TO. I HATE TO BE A
GLASS HALF FULL PERSON AT OUR
HALF AND HALF. I DON'T KNOW THE
LATER HALF ANGEL HALF EMPTY ONE
OF THAT I DON'T KNOW WHICH
ONE'S BETTER- A FULL WE HAVE
JUST LIKE PAID. PAID SICK LEAVE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE CALIFORNIA
LED THE WAY WE JUST- AND IN NO
WAY BY ONE TAKE IT BECAUSE I
KNOW HOW LONG YOU WORK ON AND I
KNOW HOW LONG THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATIONS WORKED I HOW
LONG ALL. RIGHT ON IT LIKE WE
SHOULD BE PROUD OF THAT WE
SHOULD BE PROUD OF WHAT WORK
OFFLINE- BUT IT AND SOMETIMES
LIKE WE BROKEN UP WHAT WE WORK
ON YOU KNOW WAIT REPLACEMENT.
AND UNIVERSAL. PENSION AND I
MEAN BUT IT'S NOT LIKE WE'RE
NOT REALLY. TAKING SOME LOSERS
WE ONE AT ALL AND WE WANT
ALRIGHT WE'VE GOT AND STILL
JUST MOVE THE BALL FOR THEIR
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE
LEADING ON THIS WE DID. AND WE
ALWAYS HAVE EXISTED BUT
SOMEHOW- AND MAYBE WE'LL HEAR
WHY. PEOPLE TEND TO BE WE GOT
IT ALL RIGHT THAT'S GOOD. AND
SO I JUST WANT TO POINT GIVE.
GIVE APPRECIATION PRODUCT LIKE
THAT OR NOT I THINK WE'RE ABOUT
TO HEAR FROM THE OTHER SIDE
HERE ON. WHAT THEIR CONCERNS
ARE BUT I KNOW THAT IT'S WOMEN
LINING UP SO. WHAT I'M HOPING
IS WILL GIVE YOU EACH TWO
MINUTES. IF YOU COULD. IF YOU
COULD INCLUDING YOUR REMARKS.
THE WAY YOU FEEL WE COULD
ACHIEVE THIS GOAL. THAT WOULD
BENEFIT WHOEVER IT IS YOU'RE
HERE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF I
THINK THAT WOULD HELP US. COME
ON UP GIVE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND WILL GIVE IT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MORE CURTIS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. I'M WE ARE
OBVIOUSLY VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
WORK FAMILY BALANCE. OUR TURNS
WITH YOU FROM IMPLEMENTATION OR
EXPAND BELIEVE PROGRAM THAT
MIGHT USE A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION THROUGH ENFORCEMENT. AND
THE COST OF LITIGATION MOVING
FORWARD ON THAT. BUT AS FAR AS
LEAVE ITSELF AS FAR AS THE WORK
FAMILY BALANCE AND WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE WITH YOU
ALL. AND WE WOULD APPRECIATE
BEING PART OF THE VARIATION OF
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TO. THANK YOU NAY CONNECTS THIS
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX TO
CAPRI ON. FIVE CALIFORNIA AS
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY FREQUENT
NERD. CHILD INTERACTIONS ARE
KEY TO STRONG BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
IN THE FIRST THREE MONTHS OF
LIFE THE RESEARCH MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT THE FIRST MONTHS AND
YEARS ARE CRUCIAL TO LIVE
SUCCESS WITH OVER 80% OF A
CHILD'S BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
HAPPENING IN THE FIRST THREE
YEARS- SO WORKING PARENTS MUST
HAVE THE ABILITY TO SPEND THESE
FIRST K<c.cyan> MONTHS OF EACH</c>
CHILD'S LIFE ESTABLISHING THAT
FOUNDATION FOR LIFE SUCCESS.
HOWEVER AS WE HEARD TODAY THERE
ARE MANY BARRIERS TO ACCESSING
THIS BY TO LEAVE THAT MAKE IT
HARDER FOR PARENTS TO BUILD
THIS FOUNDATION SO WE WANT TO
THANK SENATOR JACKSON
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALES FOR
SHINING A LIGHT ON THESE
DEVASTATING VERY VERY YEARS.
HELLO IMPORTANCE OF PAID LEAVE
AS WELL AS THE NEW SOME FOR AS
COMMITMENT ENSURING ALL
CALIFORNIA BABIES ARE THE BEST
START IN LIFE BEGINNING WITH
THIS CRUCIAL PARENT CHILD NING
TIME AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION TO
IMPROVE HIS FAMILY ALL OF OUR
FAMILIES. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE ANY OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT OF ANY KIND. ALL
RIGHT WELL WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES SO- LET ME. JUST IF I
COULD ASK WATER TO QUESTION.
TWO AGAIN IF YOU WOULD. ARE
TURNING GOLD STANDARD WHAT
SHOULD WE BE STRIVING TO IT. I
THINK I MEAN REALISTICALLY
REALISTICALLY THAT TAKES ABOUT
CANNOT. REALISTICALLY IN CULVER
I WHAT THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION I
MEAN WE'RE GOING INTO THE STATE
I MEAN THIS YEAR WE HAD A
PLANNING MEETING ON MONDAY WE
ACTUALLY BROUGHT PEOPLE FROM LA
TO TALK ABOUT THIS IS ONE OF
THE THINGS WE REALLY WANT TO DO
IS SEE WHERE. ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT COALITION PARTNERS
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE YOU
KIND OF LAND ON THAT BUT WE DO
HAVE A PLATFORM THAT WE'RE
DEVELOPING THAT IS REALLY LOOKS
AT AT LEAST EXTENDING YOU KNOW
PAID LEAVE MORE SIX SETTING IT
TO TWELVE WEEKS BECAUSE IT
LOOKS LIKE THAT'S ON THE
HORIZON THEN REALLY THAT THAT
BEING THE ULTIMATE TIME I'M A
COUPLE YEARS AGO. WE TALKED
ABOUT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION SAYING A YEAR-
WHETHER THAT'S YOU KNOW PARENTS
TAKING TURNS ARE DIFFERENT WHAT
TO DO AT FOR BONDING YOU KNOW
BUT JUST HAVING MORE TIME BUT A
LOT OF WHAT WE REALLY FOCUS
INTERPRETIVE SEQUENCING IS THE-
SHOP. ACTION WHICH WE THINK.
WITH YOUR PLACEMENT THAT IT.
KIND OF. STARTING TO TALK WITH
A CALIBER FED ON HOW DOES THAT
LOOK IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T
EITHER JEOPARDIZE THE FIND. AND
OVER TAX LOW WAGE WORKERS TO
HELP WHAT IT WHAT CAN WE COME
TO YOU. AROUND THAT SO THESE
ARE KINDS OF THE- YOU KNOW A
BIG THINGS AND THEN REALLY.
SOME OF THE MORE INVISIBLE
THINGS ARE HAVING WORKERS AT
THE TABLE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT. JENNA POINTED OUT THAT
ARE ABOUT HOW PEOPLE APPLY WE
KNOW THAT CARE GIVER
APPLICATIONS ARE PROCESSED
DIFFERENTLY- WE KNOW THAT IT'S
NOT SO EASY FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES TO HOLD A VOTE TO.
OPT IN TO PAY LEAVE WE KNOW
THAT. A CONTRACTOR DOESN'T
NECESSARILY KNOW HOW TO GET
INTO THE DA YOU EE PROGRAMMER.
I NEEDED TO DO IT SIX MONTHS
AGO. THAT MAKE ANY SENSE.
THERE'S A LOT OF THAT JUST HAS
TO BE. EVENED OUT IN THOSE
AREN'T REALLY EXCITING ACT.
THINGS TO WORK ON. A LOT OF
PEOPLE. REALLY THREW DOWN IN LA
YOU TALKING TO THE EASY D.
ABOUT. THE SPANISH NOT BEING
TOLD TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. IS
THAT THEY- HAVE BECAME A THAT'S
A BIG THING AND WE ACTUALLY
THINK THAT WE NEED. TO WORK
WITH THE EDT ON PUSHING THIS
FORWARD AND WORK WITH OUR-
LEGISLATORS THAT'S PARTLY BY
WE'RE GOING INTO THE FIELD. BUT
I DO THINK THAT I'M REALLY
UNIVERSAL JOB PROTECTION. IS
THAT THE KEY AND WAGE
REPLACEMENT- UP TO. REALLY A
100% FOR A LOT OF LOW WAGE
WORKERS HOWEVER WE- ACHIEVE
THAT IN A- THAT MEANS THE FIND
HAS LONGEVITY. ARE KIND OF THE
TOP LINE ISSUES THANK YOU ANY
OTHER. OKAY WELL. I JOIN THE
CLOSING OF ENDED UP PRESS SURE
AGAIN I JUST WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PARTICIPANTS- AND LOOK FOR
DAY DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
CHAMBER AND HOW WE CAN THAT
WORK TOGETHER TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD- I ACTUALLY THINK
REALISTIC ISN'T. BUT SHOULD.
CONTROL OUR IDEAS IT'S- WHAT
WOULD BENEFIT THE STATE THE
MOST AND WE KNOW IT'S NOT JUST
THE WORKER OR THE PARENT IT'S
THE CHILD- IT'S THE COMPANIES
AND OUR WAY OF LIFE SO- I THINK
THAT SOMETIMES WHERE WE'RE AT.
IN A SHOCKING FOR ME TO SAY
WERE SO CONTROLLED BY WHAT IS
REALISTIC THAT WE DON'T DO THE
TYPE OF HARD BIG STRUCTURAL
CHANGES WE NEED IN ORDER TO DO
WHAT'S RIGHT. AND SO I HOPE
WE'LL DO THAT I HOPE I WANT TO
THEIR OWN PARTICULAR FOR COMING
IN AND SHARING HER STORY THERE
IS NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT IN
ANY FIELD OF WORK I'M AND WHEN
IN TRYING TO GET CHANGE THAT
MEANS SOMEBODY WITH THEIR
FIRST. STORY BE ABLE TO COMMON
EXPRESS THAT ALCUIN WEIGHING
YOU DID IT A AND I THANK YOU
IT'S A IT'S A DIFFICULT- WE- IN
SOMETIMES IT'S HARD FIRST
INTERNALIZE AS AS TO WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES WE WORK SO HARD TO
CHANGE THE LAWS. IN WHEN THE
LIGHTS STILL. WORK FOR THE
PEOPLE. THAT DEFICIT. AT THAT
IT'S A LOT OF STATION FOR YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY BUT IT'S
DEVASTATING TO US AND WE- SAT.
SO THANK YOU FOR SHARING WITH
US TODAY. SO JUST SO THAT YOU
DON'T THINK THAT WE WERE ON A
DIFFERENT PAGE WHAT BENEFITS
THE STATE MOST IS WHAT'S MOST
REALISTIC. THERE YOU GO. I KNOW
YOU'RE NOT YOU SEE THE GLASS IS
HALF FULL. GOT AND WE WANT TO
FILL THE GLASS AS MUCH AS WE
CAN AND- I THINK THAT HAVING
PEOPLE HERE TODAY AND SURE I
AGREE YOU KNOW THERE IS NOTHING
LIKE THE PERSONAL STORY WE DE
HUMANIZE THINGS WHEN WE TALK IN
THE ABSTRACT FROM THIS ALL
ABOUT PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
FAMILIES IT'S ALL ABOUT OUR
FUTURE. TALK ABOUT OUR QUALITY
OF LIFE A AND IT'S HARD TO PUT
A PRICE TAG ON THAT A WHAT WE
NEED TO DO AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THE CHAMBER WAS HERE. IS
TO BRING ALL THE IFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE- THIS
IS IMPERATIVE FOR THE FUTURE OF
OUR STATE. AND A LOOK FORWARD
TO AS YOU MENTIONED THE
GOVERNOR'S VERY ACTIVELY
ENGAGED IN THIS WHETHER IT'S
ARE HAVING YOUNG CHILDREN AND
HAVING BEEN A CARE GIVER TO HIS
DAD WHO. RECENTLY PASSED AWAY I
THINK WE ALL HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THE HUMANITY IN WHICH WE LIVE
AND DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROTECT THAT SO WITH THAT I
WANT TO THANK- MY CO CHAIR OR I
GUESS. CHAIR FROM THE ONLY
COMPANY AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY FOR COMING- STAFF WHO
DID A GREAT JOB ON THIS FROM OF
BOTH HOUSES I HOPE WILL HAVE A
MORE I HOPE WHAT WILL BE THE
WORK AT CLOSE TO GOV WHEN HIT
THE- COMMITTEES. CORD COMES UP
AND WE DO SOME GOOD WORK. THE
PEOPLE WE ALL. SERVE AND WHO
ARE UP. RICHARD